again
i'm sorry
he's been bought off
this video
how would i do that because i'm stupid
i don't i don't may not need it at all
it's just i just want to know how to do
it
good morning ladies and gentlemen it's
10 o'clock it's time for me to formally
open this inquiry
first of all can i just check can
everyone hear me can those at the back
let's give a wave thank you
my name's david wildsmith i'm a
chartered engineer and chartered town
planner
i've been appointed by the secretary of
state to hold this inquiry
and to determine this appeal which is
made by bloor homes aber limited
aw squire limited
dw squire limited who i'll now refer to
as the appellants
under section 78 of the town and country
planning act 1990
against the decision by rochford
district council
to refuse outline planning permission
for the demolition of numbers 148 and
150 ashington road
removal of highway tree form an access
onto ashington road and a secondary
access onto perte persicottis road
to serve the residential development of
662 dwellings and a community building
with associated infrastructure
details of phase 1 of 233 dwellings to
consider access layout
appearance scale and landscaping
details of phases 2 and 3 to consider
access and layout only
and this is all on land east of
washington road and north of rochford
garden way rochford essex
before i go any further i realize i
perhaps should have just double checked
that the live stream is in fact working
yeah i've got a thumbs up at the back
thank you
so for the benefit of those who are less
familiar with public inquiries i just
need to explain i've got a number of
opening remarks and matters that i need
to cover first
so in a moment i'll invite those uh who
want to appear and are wishing to speak
at this inquiry to confirm their names
and details
i'll then need to clarify some of the
documentation for the appeal
i'll then explain the procedure to be
followed for the inquiry
and finally i'll set out the main issues
for consideration in this appeal
there's quite a lot to get through there
that'll take me 40 to 45 minutes all
told
i'll then invite the representatives of
the appellants the council and the
rushford supporters group who are
appearing as a rule six party
to make brief opening statements to set
out the basic details of their
respective cases
i'll then hear from those interested
persons who've requested to speak
following that which may take most of
today or at least
the first part of the afternoon inquiry
will then move on to the presentation
and questioning of evidence from the
main parties
council first
then the rochford supporters group
finally the appellants
as i say there's a number of important
housekeeping matters that i need to
raise the first is to say i'm grateful
for the council
for making the necessary arrangements uh
to hold this inquiry as a face-to-face
physical event
we all of course need to have regard to
the fact that as a country we're still
not on top of covid
i therefore ask
those present as much as possible
to continue to socially distance as
appropriate use the hand sanitizers
regularly please wear a face mask when
moving around in this building but
clearly when you're seated
or addressing the inquiry then you can
remove that face covering
i think we're all anticipating some
relaxation of the kobe guidelines later
this week but regardless of what's
announced i would still request all
inquiry attendees to follow the
guidelines that i've just outlined for
the duration of this inquiry
and in that way it's my hope that the
inquiry can be conducted in a safe and
efficient manner
secondly i need to make you all aware of
the fact that the inquiry is being live
streamed on the council's
website this means that for anyone who
simply wishes to observe proceedings
they can do so from the comfort of their
own home
you therefore only need to attend the
inquiry
if you're actively
participating and i would encourage
anyone who's simply attending today
simply to observe to consider not
attending on subsequent days but to
avail yourself of the live stream
in order to keep the numbers attending
this venue down to the minimum uh
appropriate
well i'd rather you don't just at the
minute um mr foster let let me go
through a few more of my points first
and and then when when you introduce
yourself you can perhaps
uh refer at that stage
so thirdly if for any of any reason any
of the intended participants find that
they are unable to attend the inquiry
venue please inform the council or the
inspectorates case officer at the
earliest opportunity
we'll then have to bring into action the
arrangements which have been made for
that person or those persons to
participate virtually
i don't spend any more time on that at
present because it may be that that
situation won't arise
but i have had confirmation earlier from
the council that the appropriate
arrangements have been made for that
eventuality i know that a link to
microsoft teams has been circulated to
those who indicated they wish to speak
fourthly i need to have a brief word
about emergency procedures just in case
the alarm sounds
i'm told that there's no practice drill
today i don't know about other days in
the week we'll come to that as the
inquiry progresses
but if the alarm does sound it's clearly
for real so we need to evacuate this
building you can see there's one fire
exit there i can see there's another one
there
i'm told that we need to assemble
near the front entrance
and if there are too many others then we
need to move to the pavement on the
opposite side of the road
so please bear that in mind if the alarm
does go
associated with that i'm going to
mention in a moment that there ought to
be an attendance list circulating i'd
encourage you all please i can see it's
there thank you i encourage you all to
put your details on that
um
obviously if there is a
fire
evacuation then knowing
who's attending uh is important so
please put your details
on the attendance list even if you're
not intending to speak
finally on housekeeping matters if
you've got a mobile phone with you
please make sure it's either switched
off or on silent whilst the inquiry is
sitting thank you
so i now need to take the names of those
who are wishing to speak during this
inquiry
so who appease appears for the
appellants please
so i do my name is miss sarah reed reid
of council
and i'll be calling two witnesses
they are mr peter blair you should have
a proof
two rebuttals and some appendices from
him
and um mr pycroft who is standing in for
mr gascoigne
and giving evidence in respect of both
housing and planning matters yes thank
you
um you you're in who are you instructed
by pleaser so sorry i'm instructed by
bloor
thank you
and for the council please
good morning sir
my name is andrew parkinson
i'm a barrister instructed by stephen
hopkins
of holmes and hill
home spell h-o-l-m-e-s
thank you
and we're calling two witnesses
um in the order that we'll call them
first of all councillor adrian eves
you have a proof and a rebuttal from him
and he'll be dealing with highways
matters
and then secondly councillor louise shaw
um who you have approved from he'll be
dealing with planning matters
so you've
of course as well had proof and rebuttal
from mr harry flexman i don't know if
you want me to deal now or later with
the position there i was going to deal
with an opening
let's deal with it later because
otherwise we'll we'll go off at tangents
and i'll get sidetracked here but yes
we'll we'll deal with that later thank
you
[Music]
so uh thank you mr parkinson and also
the as i mentioned earlier the rushford
supporters group hearings are all six
parties so who's representing that group
good morning sir thank you
my name is ian foster
i will be
representing the rochford supporters
group
um chris austin here will assist me
whilst i'm presenting evidence
we've got to have some charts that will
be in the middle there and chris will be
pointing to the relevant points as i
talk to them okay that's helpful thank
you you your procedural point do you
want to just raise it now while you're
speaking well yes sir i'll raise it now
if i may um late yesterday evening
i received a statement of common ground
a signed statement of common ground
on the subject of severity it was signed
by mr flexman and it says on behalf of
the local planning authority in the
rocha district council
and it was signed by mr blair on behalf
of the appellants
[Music]
to my knowledge and it was confirmed to
me earlier
no
member acting on behalf of the council
or
elected
member
was party to that being signed
and we would suggest therefore that that
should not be admissible as evidence
okay well i i understand
you you've raised it now mr parkinson
can always
deal deal with those points later but as
i said a moment ago i i don't want to
get sidetracked from the other points
that i now need to go through in my
opening announcements thank you
so thank you mr foster
now i've also been informed that a
number of interested persons would like
to speak can i check
if you're present please there's quite a
long list
first
i'm going to ask right honourable mark
francois mp
to address the inquiry mr francoise can
i just check that you're present
thank you
so um
you indicated when you attended the uh
case management conference mr francoise
that you're uh ideally you would like to
speak late morning or whatever today i
i'm
expecting to invite you to speak after
immediately after we have a morning
break which will be
close to half past 11 that sort of time
okay
yeah certainly i i've seen no problem in
that in terms of the order for the other
speakers i have no
particular order i'll say it now and
i'll say it several times what i don't
want to do is hear repetitive evidence
so i don't want to hear the same point
or a very similar point raised many
times by different people
a good point will carry weight whether
it's made by one person or many it
doesn't increase in its weight if
the more people who make it so for those
people who are going to speak please
listen to what other people have said
before you if they say the points that
you want to make simply tell me that you
agree with earlier speakers rather than
repeating the same points that they've
made well let me just go through this
this list
i think there's possibly about 18 or so
people
who've requested to speak
and again i'll say at this point
i have asked that anyone who wants to
speak
i'd like to have a copy of their
statement in writing
that's simply so that when you give your
statement i don't have to keep making
detailed notes of what it is you're
saying i can concentrate on what you're
saying i can annotate your notes if i
need to so i know that some of you have
already submitted a statement so thank
you for that
any of you present today who want to
speak who've indicated that you want to
speak
haven't yet submitted a copy of your
statement even if it's just speaking
notes rather than any formal statement
please see someone from the council
before i invite you to speak and they
can copy uh
that statement or those speaking notes
let me have a copy and let the other
main parties have a copy so that's what
i would expect as i say i know that some
people have already given statements
so just let me run through this list of
the people who
i'm
expecting may want to speak and if you
can just
let me know whether you're here or not
so barbara beer
thank you
benjamin crafts
no
uh
denise crosby
here but not speaking okay
i've got a doctor and mrs cj and jm
taylorson
thank you
helen wright
jane gay
no
and now jim cripps i think mr crips
perhaps wanted to speak at one stage
then said that he needed to shield but
has submitted a written
representation
so
so i'm not seeing him here today thank
you
john fuller
thank you so you're representing
southeast essex friends of the earth
and i did have a copy of your statement
handed to me earlier today i don't know
whether the other main parties did but
we'll we'll check that before i invite
you to speak
leanne dolby
mark
sorry mick vanner
oh yes yes i do recall he said that he
wouldn't be able to be here until two
o'clock yeah thank you
um penny and mark hichman
no
sharon taylor eve
thank you
sally cottis
no
sarah jones
thank you
kevin stephens
thank you
roger gardner yes thank you
uh
i've got i've got a clark dolby here
thank you
so
that was
that was the list
that i'd got is there anyone else
present who wanted to speak who hasn't
given me their details yes sir you are
okay thank you sorry i i i didn't hear
all of that too clearly but i i think i
understood that he's saying you're
speaking separately and you have
submitted copies i don't think that's
found its way to me yet but i'm sure it
will do as the morning progresses thank
you
um
anyone else
no okay thank you
so as i said as things currently stand
i'm expecting mr francoise to speak
after the mid-morning break
um
i'll then move on to hear those
remaining interested persons some in the
morning and then it'll sound so it's
going to quite likely spin over until
this afternoon
i haven't got any particular order so i
what i'll intend doing is just calling
people in the order that i read out a
moment ago but i just checked does
anyone who wants to speak have any
particular time constraints
which means that they might need to
speak
earlier or later
no okay we'll we'll work through that
sorry
sorry tell me your name again
sarah jones early okay yeah
um
see what else i need to say there then
i don't think there's anything
more
if if you if you want to speak and
haven't
so far said so
you're not barred from speaking but
the same would apply i'd need to have a
written statement from you before you
speak and i wouldn't want to hear
repetitive evidence as i've said a
moment ago
also as i mentioned a moment ago there
should be an attendance list circulating
i'm not sure how far it's it's gone it's
still doing the rounds so that's good so
just a reminder please to put your
details on that even if you don't
um intend speaking
uh it's obviously
made its way well round the room by now
i should have said this earlier but
clearly if you put your contact details
on personal email on there then it's
possible well
clearly the case that others attending
the inquiry will see those details if
for any reason you don't want that to
happen then please just put your name
and details on a separate piece of paper
and hand that to me before you leave the
inquiry
okay thank you
so moving on
mr parkinson i've received a copy of the
council's letter of notification that
was on my desk when i arrived today i
think i'd already seen a copy of that
and details of who the letters were sent
to
um now in response to the various
notifications
the planning inspector has been notified
as a number of people wish to speak at
the inquiry and i've obviously just gone
through the list of those
in addition there were a number of
people who simply submitted written
representations i just need to check
that the other parties have seen those
representations
so
of those people
who contacted the inspectorate
um but whose name i haven't already read
out if you can just check please i've
got um christine jarrett
elaine archer
keith randall steve kimberly
julie babb
jean craven
and christopher smith
all wrote in
[Music]
sent in written representations opposing
the proposal um
if the main parties can check whether
you've seen those if if you haven't and
you want copies of those then i do have
them here and i'll leave them in a blue
folder on the front of my desk so others
can copy those if need be thank you
can i just check as well have any of the
main parties received any notifications
or representations direct
no no i'm aware no no
no okay thank you
um
i do need to say of course that i've
also seen the significant number of
representations that were submitted at
planning application stage and i shall
of course take all representations into
account when i make my decision
so turning now to proofs of evidence and
the statements of common ground i've
received
proofs of evidence from all main parties
together with a number of rebuttal
proofs i think two from the council's
witnesses
um well i'll say two one was from mr
flexman and one from council reeves
two from mr blair for the appellants
in addition i've seen the uh
short time lapse video which the rule
six party has submitted in rebuttal to
some of the appendices in mr blair's
evidence
i've read all the proofs and the
rebuttal proofs i've viewed the time
lapse video
what i haven't had the opportunity to do
is go in detail through all of the
appendices to the proofs all of the
attachments and the core documents
so so may i add
there is no statement of common ground
with
they're all sick
you're one step ahead of me uh sorry
just just abide your time
we will get there
um
so i say i haven't had the opportunity
to go through all of the the documents
in great detail i've done the proofs
through rebuttal proofs um done the
video gone through the appendices but
there will be bits in the attachments
and the core documents that i haven't
necessarily gone through in great detail
so the reason i'm saying this i i want
advocates and witnesses to take me to
those points
when presenting their evidence thank you
so i said a moment ago
statements of common ground
i've got
a highway statement of common ground
between the appellants and essex county
council as local highway authority
dated the 29th of november 21.
a statement of common ground on housing
supply and delivery
between the appellants and rochford
district council dated the 7th of
december 21
a planning statement of common ground
between the appellants and rochefort
district council dated the 17th of
december 2021
and
a highway statement of common ground
between the appellants and the council
dated the 19th of january
22.
now i am aware it's been raised already
and i've seen the email this morning
that there is an extra statement of
common ground on highways between the
appellants
and the council
i'm sure that's going to be
highlighted by mr parkinson in a moment
i'm also aware that an attempt was made
to produce a statement of common ground
between the appellants and the royal six
party but that did not prove to be
possible
such that there's no such statement of
common ground before me at this inquiry
so that's the point you're making his
nips to foster thank you
so for anyone following this inquiry
online copies of the proofs of evidence
and other relevant documents can be
found on the council's website
on the planning application page under
reference i believe it's 20 stroke
00363 stroke out
like what i would often do is
produce an inquiry timetable which can
also go on the website so that people
who are
dipping in and out of the inquiries at
work and know
at what time certain elements may take
place i haven't done that yet for this
one and obviously things may change
with um
withdrawal of witnesses etc but i i will
do my best to
do a an inquiry timetable that can be
posted on the website later
i just wanted to check mr parkinson i
don't know if you're the right person to
ask for this but are all inquiry
documents on the website it's the things
like the core documents that i wasn't
sure i see a nod from one of your
colleagues further along
the table so core documents can be found
on that same website
okay thank you so if you heard that if
if you hear bits in the evidence and a
core document is referred to when you
want to check what that was all about
then there is a set of documents
out there
do the documents out there also include
copies of proofs of evidence have the
parties been able to put spare copies of
their proofs of evidence out there
if
if you haven't and you have spare
coppers if you're able to that would be
helpful
so we can arrange that today yeah okay
thank you
now all documents and evidence should
already have been provided
but if you intend to submit anything
else please let me know as soon as
possible any such documents will need to
be
supplied in hard copy but also i'd like
an electronic version sent to the
inspectors case officer thank you
i assume as well that they would be
automatically uploaded to the council's
website
thank you thank you
there is one document i don't know
whether you want me to mention it now or
it's nothing major
um
no
tell me tell me when you introduce the
council's case okay
that way thank you
sir i'm so sorry to interrupt now um it
was the we received a message from pins
asking for redaction of um
oh i'm so sorry hang on let me move that
[ __ ]
it's it's
too much now isn't it is that better
yeah okay i'm so sorry we serve we
received a notification from pins in
respect to some of the photographs that
you're included in mr blair's evidence
coming onto that so would you want me to
i think the thing is i i i won't
consider it discourteous if you don't
look at me while talking so
address address your microphone but i
know i know that you you're actually
talking to me difficult yeah that's the
difficulty um we received notification
from pins in respect to the photographs
in mr blair's proof of evidence i know
the rule six party's also been working
to
carry out the same exercise in respect
of its evidence and we've got some hard
copies um that you may wish to be
substituted for those that you've got in
respect of those photographs so we have
those available we have three copies one
for the council one for the rule six
party um so at an appropriate time if
you wish to receive that that's
available yes thank you for that
it was elsewhere in my notes but you
might as well have said it there but yes
that that's fine
just to ensure that uh
photos have been suitably redacted and
there were a few that needed to be
amended so thank you for that thank you
okay let me sorry sir i should add
likewise we've got some extra
photographs i think some went out
yesterday and they may not been received
by everybody we'll have copies to hand
out
that's great thank you very much mr
foster thank you
so turn into the way in which the
inquiry will proceed
it's currently been allocated four days
now the initial time estimates that i
had received
led me to consider that that would be
unlikely to be sufficient time to
undertake all the necessary business
including an accompanied site visit
which i'll return to shortly
so we'll we'll come back to look at
duration and site visit in a moment but
on a daily basis i intend to break for
lunch for about an hour at a convenient
point at around one o'clock when i'll
review progress
i'll take short breaks or adjournments
mid-morning and mid-afternoon as
appropriate
and i'll generally look to the advocates
to find an appropriate break in
proceedings for those short comfort
breaks
i'd hope to not have to sit much beyond
5 or 5 30
each day
depending on progress it may be
necessary to start slightly earlier on
some days possibly 9 30 if that would be
acceptable to the parties
can i just check are there any
limitations on uh
time that we can use this room it looks
so it's given over for the inquiry
right
yeah understood thank you
so the same would apply that you you
wouldn't want to sit beyond five
yep
thank you
and so
if if this room is given over for the
inquiry then presumably we can leave
documents in here overnight etc
okay thank you
so for those of you who may not be
familiar with the rules relating to
inquiries i need to explain that the
inquiry has two main purposes
first is to enable me to obtain all the
information i need to make my decision
the second is to give all those who wish
to speak the opportunity of a fair and
open hearing
so in summary the procedure will be as
follows firstly i'll set out what i
currently regard as the main issues
before the inquiry and any other matters
upon which i'll wish to hear evidence
the fact that i may not identify a
particular matter doesn't prevent it
from being raised so long as it is a
relevant matter
i'll then invite the appellants advocate
miss reed to make a brief opening
statement of about five to ten minutes
simply outlining the appellant's case
i'll then invite mr parkinson for the
council to do the same mr foster to do
the same for the rule six party
that will help or present to better
understand the basis of the main party's
cases
having heard those brief statements i'll
then invite those interested persons
who've indicated that they would like to
speak to make their statement
misread for the appellants may have
questions for you
i may also have some questions
when all interested persons have spoken
i'll ask the council's advocate mr
parkinson to call his witnesses in turn
to present their evidence
they those witnesses may be
cross-examined by
the appellant's advocate miss
again i may also have questions for
those witnesses
finally each witness may be re-examined
by
his or her
own advocate in order to clarify answers
that they've given
when the council's witnesses have been
heard i'll hear the rule six party uh
present its case
as i've said questions may be asked by
the appellants and i may also have
questions
we'll then move on and hear the
appellant's case but before i do i'll
just double check then that there aren't
any other interested persons who haven't
spoken who feel they want to speak
because i want to make sure that i've
heard all
opposing
views to the appellant's case before i
invite the appellants to
present their evidence
so the appellants will
make their case following the same
procedure
both the council and the rule 6 party
will have the opportunity to
cross-examine the appellant's witnesses
although of course i wouldn't want that
to involve any repetition of matters
i will also give an opportunity for
those interested parties
who are opposing the proposal and who've
spoken earlier in the inquiry to put
questions to the appellant's witnesses
provided that they they've already
indicated they want to speak and
provided they don't simply repeat
questions already put to that witness
again i may have questions for the
appellant's witnesses and miss reed will
then have the opportunity to re-examine
witnesses to clarify points made
so that will complete the evidence the
main evidence i then intend to have a
discussion on any conditions which might
be appropriate in the event that i
decide that this appeal should be
allowed i'll return to that in a moment
it'll also be necessary to have a
general discussion
uh
to
a general discussion about the planning
obligation which i've so far seen in
draft form that's another matter i'll
refer returned to shortly
so on conclusion of that process i'll
first ask any interested party then the
rule six party then the council then the
appellant to make their closing
submissions to me
because for the benefit of interested
persons present there's no requirement
that you make a closing
summary of your case i should say that
closing submissions
isn't an opportunity for you to
introduce anything new to the inquiry
it's simply an opportunity if you so
wish to summarize the points that you've
already made
i'll then establish whether there's any
other matters to be considered before
making arrangements for the accompanied
site visit
having done so i'll close the inquiry
now in practice it may be preferable to
hold the site visit before the final
submissions are given
that gives the main parties a bit more
time to finalize their closing
submissions
i understand also that there may be some
concern about road works in the area so
the the timing of the accompanying
cybers is something we'll have to return
to as the inquiry progresses i don't
want to
dwell on it at the minute now as i say
we'll discuss that point
later
so that's a run through the
the way the inquiry will be held are
there any questions about procedure
mr foster apology say i should have
mentioned that in the opening speech uh
mrs austin will be sharing that with me
i will start and she'll complete it if
that's okay
i don't see a problem with that thank
you
thank you
so
as i said a moment ago it's been
allocated
four days
from my initial reading of the papers
and from what's been said i think we may
have difficulty
fitting all of the business into the
currently allocated time i did refer to
this at the case management conference
for this appeal when i when it was
agreed that it would be prudent to
reserve a couple of days
next week
uh if necessary obviously we'll get a
better feel for that once the inquiry is
underway but can i just check the
availability of the parties and this
room if we do overrun to next week
room's okay
okay and we're okay in terms of
attendance
okay
everyone okay
yes thank you sir okay good thank you
so um i said a moment ago conditions and
planning obligation
we'll need to discuss what planning
conditions might be appropriate if i was
to allow this appeal
i should make it clear to interested
person this is standard procedure
the fact that conditions will need to be
discussed doesn't mean that i intend to
allow this appeal nor does it weaken the
council's opposition to the proposal
i may ask the witnesses questions about
conditions when i hear their evidence
and in any event i intend to hold an
open discussion
about conditions towards the end of the
inquiry
i've not seen an updated list of
suggested conditions what i have seen
is the schedule of i think it's 52
conditions which were included
in the 24th of june 2021 committee
report
can i just check with the main parties
are those conditions still being worked
on
so i'm just taking instructions but i
understand that there was an updated
list of conditions that were sent to the
inspectorate okay
just before christmas but we'll check
the position check it with the local
authority
and revert on that point yeah thank you
thank you yeah
i mean it could certainly have gone
through and it might just be one of
those that i i haven't picked up but as
long as
it's
if i can have a copy of that
updated list i ideally buy um close of
play tomorrow i can then go through that
i can give the parties my
initial views on those conditions if
there's anything i feel that we will
need to highlight sooner rather than
later
um i take it that the conditions are
primarily between the council
and the appellants in terms of how
they've been
prepared
mr foster i don't know if the rule six
parties um
seen
this list of conditions and obviously
you'll you'll be able to make comments
on when we have the uh
the open session on conditions later in
the inquiry sure we're fine with that
thank you thank you so we'll make sure
that the updated list is passed to the
rule six party as well thank you thank
you
uh yes so i said if i can have that by
close of play tomorrow that'll be
helpful
um
i've also received
an updated draft section 106 planning
obligation in the form of an agreement
um what's the latest position on that
please i'll look to both the appellants
and the council
um when am i to expect a signed and
completed version
my understanding is
my understanding is that the contents
agree between the appellant and the
council and we're waiting for the county
council to come back on
some of the contributions i think that's
that's position okay
so that's right um we're dealing with
the solicitor at the county now there's
just been a little hiccup in terms of
the availability of the person dealing
with it which is why there's been a
delay as far as we understand so again
we'll revert as soon as we
we have an update in that respect
okay but we're on target for
uh a signed version
before the inquiry closes are we
think so sir okay
hopefully thank you
so
what else i got to say
i was going to say that i hadn't seen
the still compliance statement but i
know that that came through yesterday so
i've i've now got
a community infrastructure levy
compliance statement
in relation to this planning obligation
we'll obviously need to go through that
at the same time as the planning
obligation later in the inquiry
so i'm close close to the end you'll be
pleased to know but still a few more
points
uh site visit now i've already um
unaccompanied seeing the
appeal site in the surrounding area from
the public highway
i've also visited
most of the other junctions that have
been referred to in evidence i will try
and undertake other accompanied visits
during the course of the inquiry and as
i've said already i would intend to
carry out an accompanied site visit
later in the proceedings ideally after
i've heard all the evidence and before i
hear closing submissions
i did ask the parties to work together
to produce a site visit itinerary and
that's been done so i've got
details of the points and the locations
that
people would like me to view
and from mr cripps i'd also received a
plan showing a wider route that he would
like me to drive so i'm quite content to
do that
i'm well aware of the fact that to the
council and the appellants did say that
they were content for me to
undertake the site visit unaccompanied
and
give me permission to enter onto the
appeal site that's that's usually the
reason why i need to be accompanied if
i'm going on to private land
but the rule sixth party indicated that
they wished to be present certainly uh
visiting a number of the the junctions
so
i'm happy to do that accompany but it
doesn't mean that i'll need to also be
accompanied by someone from the
appellants and from the council at the
same time
and just
for clarification the site visit isn't
an opportunity for people to provide
additional evidence
and bend my ear as it were
i'm more than happy to have physical
features pointed out when we're on the
site or undertaking the site visit but i
don't need to hear people's views or
any attempt to provide evidence i'll
rely on my own observations and the
evidence that's been presented
in the inquiry
so as i said earlier um i could carry
out the site visit after i've closed the
inquiry
um
i usually like to try and
slot it in before hearing the accounts
at the party's closing submissions
in case anything seen at the site visit
needs to be discussed at the inquiry and
as i said a moment ago it also gives
advocates a little bit more time to
complete their closing submissions
do the parties have any thoughts on this
i say i don't want to
try and pin down the time for this now
but
what's the party's views on
timing of the site visit
so i think we we'd also prefer
an accompanying visit shortly before
closings for for all the reasons you've
said and in particular the extra time it
will give us to write those closings i
mean i think at this point
might be a question of seeing where we
are
by the end of the week and
working out the best time to to do it
then depending on if we're coming back
next week and when we're coming back
next week yes of course
miss reed so um flexible in that respect
um just with the caveat um that mr
parkinson and i and the rule six party
have sufficient
time to draft our closing submissions
um that would be my overriding comment
in respect of it but in if for example
we're into next week in any case and
we've had time to do that um flexible
okay thank you
mr foster any comments about the site
visit them um we did
when we submitted the proposals put some
times in there um thursday morning
is generally a good opportunity to view
ashton road and the various junctions
around here
as i say we did put those um
those times in this in the suggestion
okay we'll
we'll keep it flexible we'll see how
things progress
through through the inquiry as i said
the ideally i like to hear all the
evidence so i know
all parties views on matters um
do the site visit then
and allow the uh
advocates time while i'm doing the visit
as it were uh to prepare closing
submissions
from an availability perspective apart
from the two council meetings already
mentioned this evening and thursday i'm
very flexible on the timing right
through the whole length of the
inquiry period that's good okay so thank
you for that and i'll say we'll
obviously have to revisit that but i
don't want to dwell on that anymore just
at the moment
so
i need to say that only exceptionally
will material received after the closure
of the inquiry be accepted uh that does
include planning obligations which is
why i said uh
hopefully we're on target for the signed
version before i close
i need to check plans i'm not going to
go through that in detail but this
proposal is for full planning permission
for phase one outline planning
permission for phases two and three
in terms of plans i've seen a list of i
think it was 32 plans
contained within condition four
in that
aforementioned schedule for the um
committee report last june
i'm told obviously there's a separate
list of of um
conditions but
presumably that
one of those conditions will still
contain a full list of plans i just need
confirmation that the plans in the
condition
are indeed those that are on which i'm
required to determine this appeal
so that can be double checked but just
your reference as well the planning
statement of common ground 3.2.1
contains an agreed list of plans okay
thank you i've got that to hand thank
you
further
yes
yeah
um i i'll have to consider that mr
francois say for the reasons i i've
already given okay thank you
um
okay
so i need to say costs
no part is so far indicated intends to
make any application for costs but the
case management conference the parents
reserve their position on this matter i
just need to say if any application is
to be made the planning practice
guidance makes it clear as a matter of
good practice it should be made in
writing ideally before the inquiry i've
received no such application
do any parties currently anticipate make
an application for costs
no sir
okay thank you
so i can move on almost finally to the
main issues
based on the evidence before me and as
agreed at the case management conference
i consider the main issues in this case
to be firstly
the extent to which the proposed
development would be consistent with the
development plan for the area
and the weight to be given to relevant
development plan policies
secondly the effect of the proposed
development in traffic and transport
terms
on the safety and convenience of users
of the nearby highway network
thirdly whether any submitted planning
obligation and planning conditions
would adequately and satisfactorily
address the impacts of the proposed
development
and
i've added a fourth um really
which is how the overall planning
balance should be assessed
um and again as i indicated at the case
management conference the appellant's
case will also need to cover any other
relevant matters
raised by the other parties or by
interested persons
anyone have any comment on the main
issues
is my microphone still working it sounds
sounds like it's gone a bit
are we still okay at the back
okay thank you
so no no
no comments in respect to the main
issues um but i have just received
instructions that when people are
speaking from the floor the live stream
isn't picking it up so i just wanted to
make you aware of that sorry say that
again what what is that being picked up
when when members of the public are
speaking yes the live stream isn't
picking up what they are saying so it's
picking up those of us with microphones
but not members of the public okay well
when members of the public do speak i'll
invite you to to come to the um the
witness table so you will be picked up
at that stage so anything that's not
being picked up so far
i've got a strange echo here isn't there
a minute
anything that's not been picked up so
far um
i i don't think is necessarily germaine
to uh or particularly germaine
to to the inquiry but
people speaking um
presenting their cases will be picked up
because you'll be at the
witness table
okay thank you
so i've been through the main issues
i've said that i've checked whether
there's any comments on the main issues
that actually concludes my opening
announcements
so what i would do now i'll invite the
three main parties to make their opening
statements
then i'll look to have a mid-morning
break and then after that we'll hear
from mr francoise and then other
interested persons
so miss reed can i invite you to make
the opening statement for the appellant
and do you have written copies i'll just
um ask them to be circulated because i'm
stuck in the corner here
so i think i can pass one to you but
i'll just ask those to be circulated
okay thank you
okay
okay
okay
well all i would say miss reid is make
sure you're nice and close to the
microphone and and
address the room right rather than me
thank you
difficult balance between echoing and
not being heard but
i'll turn i'll turn mine off i don't
know if there's any feedback but i'll do
that while i'm not speaking at the
minute
so this is an appeal against the refusal
of an application for 662 dwellings
community building an associated
infrastructure on land east of ashington
road and north of rochford garden way
232 of the proposed dwellings will be
affordable homes
the site is located at the top of the
council's settlement hierarchy and is
allocated this is therefore a genuinely
plan led scheme which delivers the
council's strategy and planned growth
for its area it is a scheme for
sustainable development that complies
with both the development plan and the
framework
there was a single reason for refusal in
respect of the scheme in summary this
was that the development would result in
a severe impact on the local highway
network
the council's single reason for refusal
does not bear scrutiny
applying the test in framework paragraph
111 the chronology in respect of the
consideration of the application and the
appeal demonstrates clearly that the
highway impacts of the development would
be acceptable
by way of summary
one through the application process
there was extensive and positive
engagement between the appellants
the statutory council the highways
authority and the professional offices
of the lpa
this included some seven pre-application
meetings with planning officers and a
planning performance agreement
the professional opinion of the highway
authority as set out in its consultation
response and has subsequently confirmed
an assigned statement of common ground
is that there would be no unacceptable
impact on highway safety and that the
residual cumulative impacts of the
proposed development would not be severe
in two carefully considered reports the
senior professional officer of the local
planning authority the assistant
director of place agreed and twice
recommended to members that the scheme
should be approved
in accordance with council's advice
which was appended to the officers
reports committee
members were advised that the opinion of
the statutory council t should be
accorded significant weight and that
there was no evidential basis to refuse
planning permission and that it would
not be reasonable for the council to do
so
that was plainly right the highways
authority is the statutory council t and
there is an obligation for the local
planning authority to have regard to its
consultation response as a material
consideration
further it is a well-established
principle that great or considerable
weight should be attributed to the view
of the statutory council t and where the
lpa departs from it there must be cogent
and compelling reasons for doing so
members nevertheless refuse planning
permission for the development without
any technical evidence to support their
position contrary to the recommendations
of their professional officer and the
highway authority
there was a single reason for refusal
that was that the development would
result in a severe impact on the local
highway network
nor did the local planning authorities
reason for refusal cite conflict with
any policies of the development plan
as already set out it is clear that
there is compliance with the policies of
the development plan the scheme is for
the development of an allocated site
that positively delivers the council's
own strategy for growth in accordance
with its own plan
at the cmc however it was confirmed on
behalf of the local planning authority
that although there is absolutely no
reference to highway safety in the
reason for refusal the lpa wished to add
to its reason for refusal by alleging
that there would also be an unacceptable
impact on highway safety
at the point that this was confirmed the
lpa did not have any technical evidence
to support that position either which
was as already set out contrary to the
recommendation of the local authorities
professional officers and the highway
authority
following the cmc the council instructed
an external professional witness to
defend members position
however that professional witness has
subsequently confirmed in a signed
statement of common ground that there
would not be an accept an acceptable
impact on highway safety and the local
planning authority again no longer
pursues the points relating to highway
safety
the lpa's position has therefore
reverted to that set out in the reason
for refusal that is that its single
reason for resisting the scheme is that
it considers that the development would
result in a severe impact on the local
highway network
however the local planning authority's
own professional witness
has now also in a signed statement of
common ground agreed that following
mitigation the residual cumulative
impacts on the road network would not be
severe
accordingly the professional witnesses
in get witness engaged by the local
planning authority to defend the appeal
also agrees that there will be no
conflict with paragraph 111 of the
framework this is therefore a scheme
that has been rigorously and extensively
assessed by multiple experts on multiple
occasions
firstly by the appellants transport
consultants through the ta and taa
secondly by the appellant's expert
witness through his review of the scheme
thirdly by the highway authority
forcedly by the local planning
authority's professional planning
officer on two occasions and now by the
professional witness instructed by the
council to defend its appeal
and the consensus of all of the
professionals is that there would not be
an unacceptable impact on highway safety
and that the residual cumulative impacts
on the road network would not be severe
thus whilst the concerns of residents
are acknowledged it is submitted that
significant weight can be attributed to
the professional consensus
the evidence here is clear and
compelling and the professional
consensus provides a robust basis for
concluding that the highways impacts of
the scheme following mitigation will be
acceptable
nevertheless and notwithstanding the
consensus that has been reached by the
professional experts including the
expert appointed to defend the local
planning authority's case it is
understood
at the time of writing and that was on
the eve of the inquiry that members
would still continue to assert that the
residual cumulative impacts on the
highway network will be severe
and the appellants will say that the
local planning authority's position is
wholly unsupported and is unsupportable
the proposal accords with all policies
of the development plan and the
framework it is manifestly a scheme for
sustainable development within the
meaning of the framework
pursuant to section 38.6 of the pcpa
planning compulsory purchase act the
starting point is the development plan
the development plan is the council's
carefully considered plan that sets out
how the development needs of the
district are to be met
mppf
paragraph 15 provides that the planning
system should be genuinely plan lead
the proposed development is genuinely
plan led because it brings forward much
needed housing and affordable housing on
a site that the council has chosen to
allocate for development
in its own development plan
this is a policy compliant plan-led
beneficial development the appellants
are delivering development in accordance
with the council's own strategy for
growth
the district of rochford is heavily
constrained by environmental and
physical constraints including greenbelt
landscape designations and congestion
across the district
the council when it adopted its core
strategy
considered all of those constraints and
took a balanced view as to distribution
of growth to meet its housing needs and
directed development to the most
sustainable locations in the district
these were the least constrained
locations for growth in the district and
where there are opportunities to
encourage alternative sustainable
transport solutions
this approach is plainly in accordance
with the framework
rochford ashington is identified as a
tier one settlement in the core strategy
and therefore sits right at the top of
the council's settlement hierarchy the
council's own development plan therefore
recognises the settlement as one of the
most suitable and sustainable locations
in the district to which housing growth
should be directed in principle
the highway authority and the local
planning authority
agree that the appeal site is within
walking and cycling distance of a
significant range of local facilities
and services
further the appeal site is an allocated
site and is therefore a site to which
development should be directed in
accordance with the council's own
strategy
as the council's senior professional
officer recorded in the office's report
the council's development plan has been
subject to extensive consultation with
residents across the district and
independent scrutiny through independent
examination process to adoption
given the allocation and policy support
for the development of the site the
officer also correctly concluded that no
objection can reasonably made to the
proposed development on the site as a
matter of principle
the delivery of a sufficient supply of
good quality housing is a national
priority but it is also expressly a
priority of the council's development
plan
the council has identified appropriate
locations to accommodate the growth
required and this settlement and the
appeals site specifically is expressly
so identified
the position that appears to be promoted
by objectors the rule six party and
councillors whereby the necessary growth
identified through the adopted
development plan should not be brought
forward on an allocated site in a
top-tier settlement
is not one that is supported by national
policy the council's development plan
or the plan led system
added to this the council's housing
needs are acute
the council is failing to deliver the
homes that its residents need in
accordance with the stated priorities of
the development plan and national policy
it has never been more important that
sites identified and allocated by the
council in its own development plan as
appropriate for growth in principle
are allowed to come forward to meet
those critical housing needs
since
2008-9 there has been a persistent and
year-on-year failure to meet even the
constrained housing requirement
identified in the plan 250
dwellings per annum
without the appeal site it is agreed
that the council cannot meet even its
housing it's actually even its
constrained housing requirement to the
end of the plan period
it is further agreed that given the
shortfall against the adopted housing
requirements the delivery of housing on
this allocated cat site carries a
minimum of significant weight
however
it is also agreed that the council's
housing requirement is a constrained
figure and is out of date because it
does not reflect the requirements of the
framework which set a higher local
housing need figure
in accordance with national policy the
council's housing need figure has
increased to
362 dwellings per annum
there is therefore a need for additional
lands come forward but as a minimum it
is clearly imperative that sites that
have been allocated through the plan-led
system
come forward to meet needs in a timely
manner
the council cannot demonstrate a
five-year housing land supply in
accordance with the minimum requirements
of national policy the council can only
demonstrate a 4.0 four-year housing land
supply and the shortfall which exceeds
the annual requirement for an entire
year
is plainly significant
the council accepts that significant
weight should be afforded to the
delivery of additional housing in these
circumstances
it is plainly right to do so additional
sites need to be released now to meet
the council's housing needs going
forward
the position in respect of affordable
housing is also stark
there has been a cumulative shortfall in
affordable housing in every single year
since the start of the plan period in
2006
the cumulative shortfall in affordable
homes now
stands at over a whopping 1
600 homes
the most recent data shows that there
were some
774 households in rochford on the
affordable housing waiting list the
council's forward supply of affordable
homes for the next five years is agreed
to be
471 homes that's for the next five years
that will not begin to scratch the
surface
of addressing the shortfall of over 1600
affordable homes
let alone account for newly arising need
those are homes that real people in real
need
require now
the position is acute and the outlook is
bleak and it is sobering and the council
is right that the addition of
232 affordable homes to the projected
affordable housing stock and which will
be delivered through the implementation
of the appeal scheme
on an allocated site
should be accorded very significant
weight in the planning balance
those are homes that are desperately
needed
now
it is agreed that the tilsa balance
applies in this case because the council
cannot demonstrate a five-year housing
land supply in those circumstances it is
plainly a significant benefit of this
scheme that the proposal will be brought
forward in accordance with
the policies of the adopted development
plan
for those reasons it is critical that
this allocated site in a location that
sits right at the top of the council's
settlement hierarchy is allowed to come
forward now in accordance with the
council's own plan
to meet the significant housing needs of
the district
the scheme will deliver a raft of
additional benefits including economic
benefits public open space including
youth facilities allotments natural
space and a locally equipped area of
play a community building on the site
flood alleviation off-seat
tree planting electrical vehicle
charging points and additional highway
improvement and sustainable transport
measures which i'll return to below
which will benefit new and existing
residents alike
the local planning authority agrees that
all other development impacts can be
adequately accommodated in this case
and the very significant obligation
package contained in the 106 obligation
contains obligations towards health care
school and expanded early years and
child care libraries improve waste
services and local youth facilities
this is plainly a scheme for sustainable
development this is in accordance with
the framework and the development plan
it is exactly the type of scheme that
the council should be welcoming with
open arms and without delay in
accordance with paragraph one one at
paragraph eleven sorry of the framework
when understood in its proper context
the council's single reason for refusal
does not bear scrutiny
first as set out whilst highway safety
did not form part of the reason for
refusal it was added subsequently by the
local planning authority
however there has always been
professional consensus between the
appellants the highway authority and the
local planning authorities professional
officer
that the scheme will be acceptable in
highway safety terms
the professional consultant engaged by
the council to defend the case has now
also confirmed that the scheme will be
acceptable in highway safety terms and
that underscores the point yet further
the scheme will plainly be acceptable in
highway safety terms
in particular whilst there will be a
reduction in the width of the pavement
outside the holt farm schools
the proposed pavement width will remain
3.25 to 4.4 metres and will continue to
provide an adequate and safe space for
users even during the short periods of
peak intensity
further additional features will in fact
enhance the pedestrian and cycle
environment and highway safety in the
vicinity of the schools
including upgrades to toucan crossing
the erection of led advanced warning
signs to the school where currently
there are none
and some 20 metres of additional guard
rail in the vicinity of the school
the design of the scheme has been
subject to an independent road safety
audit and is acceptable in highway
safety terms and the council has now
withdrawn its objection
that the package of measures is simply
renewing
that which exists
the net result in respect of highway
safety
is plainly beneficial
highway capacity has also been carefully
considered
the council says that it accepts the
principle of development on the site as
a result of its allocation
that must be right
what that means however is that it is
inevitable that there will be additional
trips that are generated associated with
bringing the site forward for
development in accordance with the
allocation within the plan
as already set out the professional
consensus
is that the residual cumulative impacts
on the highway network would not be
severe and that the scheme is in
accordance with the framework paragraph
111
the highway authority and the local
planning authority's professional
witness
accept that the appellant's modeling in
respect of junction 2 the site access
junction 1 ashington road rectory road
junction 5 the south end sutton road or
amber lim roundabout is appropriate
the outputs of the modelling demonstrate
that following mitigation those
junctions will operate within capacity
and will in fact perform better than the
base case without development
the local planning authority's
professional witness has not challenged
those conclusions in his evidence
and the highway statement of common
ground with him
confirms that there are no outstanding
issues between the professional
witnesses
following further discussion revised
modelling results in respect of junction
3 the ashington road at roche avenue
junction
have also been agreed between the
experts as an alternative reasonable
approach to modeling
however
even in the worst case residual impacts
demonstrated in that model can be
acceptably mitigated by a simple scheme
secured through the section 106
obligation as set out in the evidence of
mr blair
this demonstrates that following
mitigation this junction can also work
within capacity and the position will
again be better than the base case
without development
the deliverability and the effectiveness
of such a mitigation scheme has been
accepted by the highway authority and
also by the local planning authority's
professional witness
it is agreed that this mitigation can be
delivered through the obligations
contained in the section 106 obligation
the appellants and the highway authority
consider that the modeling at junction 4
ashington road
hall road west street junction is robust
the local planning authority's
professional witness has raised no
issues with that revised modelling by mr
blair which demonstrates better results
than those which the highways authority
accept
it has long been accepted that the
forecast traffic impacts cannot be
mitigated by highways improvements
at this junction because as a recognized
in the offices reports committee
no junction improvements are possible
here because of constraints on the
ground
the highway authority accepts that the
suite of non-highway work mitigations
which enhance sustainable travel
encourage modal shift and promote active
travel are suitable mitigation
these issues were known when the council
allocated the site and nevertheless
growth is anticipated in this top-tier
settlement and on the appeal site
specifically
and the council accepts the
acceptability and principle of the
proposed development
indeed the policies of the core strategy
expressly recognize that given the
constraints in the district in order to
deliver the necessary growth some
highway impacts are in the words of
policy t1 inevitable
and it therefore commits to working with
the highways authority to resolve wider
issues within the network and
specifically along washington road
policy t2 whilst simultaneously
directing development to the most
sustainable locations and encouraging
developers to deliver initiatives to
reduce reliance on the private car and
implement schemes to deliver appropriate
improvements where possible
that is exactly what is proposed here
the scheme will secure a number of
additional benefits in highway and
sustainability terms these include
pedestrian and cycle links will be
provided across the appeal site and will
open up alternative routes to king
edmond school and waterman primary
school diverting pedestrians and
cyclists off washington road and
removing pedestrians and cyclists from
the holtz farm schools frontage
additional significant contributions
towards enhancing sustainable transport
choices including upgrades to cycling
infrastructure to connect with the town
centre and employment sites
bus stop upgrades and service
enhancements and a commitment to what
the highway authorities agree is
a comprehensive travel plan that will
further reduce reliance on the private
car
those measures will have a positive
impact for the benefit of both residents
of the appeal site and also the wider
community
the provision of dedicated off-street
parking for the school drop off and pick
up is a further benefit of the scheme
because firstly the spaces will be
dedicated and secondly there will be a
net increase in the number of spaces
available over those existing now
and the council has withdrawn its
objection in respect of parking
a section 106 obligation secures the sum
of money for immunity enhancements at
the school which can provide an
additional focal point for off-street
gathering for pupils and parents at
school drop-off and pick-up time
in short there is now professional
consensus that the scheme will be
acceptable in terms of highway safety
the residual cumulative impacts of the
scheme will not be severe within the
meaning of the framework and will be
mitigated as far as practicable but in
any event to an acceptable degree in
accordance with framework 111 and will
deliver positive sustainability and
highway benefits
the proposal is in accordance with the
policies of the development plan
including those relating to traffic t1
dm 31 and also ser 8 which allocates the
site for development
for all of those reasons the appellants
will submit that this is a scheme for
sustainable development
the tilted balance applies in this case
and it is a significant benefit of the
scheme in these circumstances that it is
a truly plan led scheme
it is a scheme that positively delivers
against the council's own strategy for
growth in accordance with the policies
of the development plan
in a settlement at the top of the
settlement hierarchy and on a site that
has been allocated for development the
scheme will provide a package of
benefits including much needed housing
and affordable housing
where there is an acute
and critical need to deliver the same
the adverse impacts of the scheme do not
come close to significantly and
demonstrably outweighing the benefits of
the scheme
when assessed against the provisions of
the framework as a whole and it will be
respectfully requested that the appeal
is allowed and permission is granted
accordingly so unless you have any
questions at this stage those are my
opening submissions no thank you miss
reed that's uh that's very comprehensive
well in excess of your 10-minute
estimate i'm afraid so that's the
and
please no applause it's a public inquiry
it's not a public meeting thank you
um i i hope that the other estimates
that you've given can be more closely
stuck too thank you
mr parkinson can i ask you to now please
thank you sir outline the council's case
um
we've got a copy of this already no no
no i'm aware of you know
i think copies have just been passed
around
also can i check if it's like this can
you hear okay
okay i'll leave it there i'll i'll turn
this one off again when you i don't know
if there is any interference between the
two but uh
i'll turn it off when i don't need to be
speaking
thank you sir i've i've i've still not
got my copy are you still not going
i'm waiting for it to arrive first um
let me give you mine
are you sure sorry i think there's a
spare one here
okay thank you
okay thank you mr parker thank you sir
the council's case at this inquiry is
simple but it's fundamental the appeal
scheme would have an unacceptable impact
on the road network
why this is the case will be explored in
detail and the evidence of councillor
eaves and as this is just an opening
i'll set up some preliminary points now
at the outset
first point ashton road is a priority
one road that plays a vitally important
role for journeys into rochford town
centre and it's already congested
second that congestion has got worse not
better in the decades since the core
strategy was adopted back in december
2011 and when development in this
location was first provided for the
development plan
then it was considered important that
new development be accompanied by
requisite highway infrastructure
improvements to mitigate their impact on
the existing network
that's a quote from the core strategy
unfortunately despite best efforts and
the improvements that have been
delivered in recent years it's not yet
been possible to deliver the original
intention that infrastructure
improvements would mitigate the impact
of new development on the highway
network
that's nobody's fault it's just the
reality of the physical constraints of
the highway network in a district that
and again this quote from the core
strategy does not lend itself to travel
without the use of a private car
and the challenges of converting that
intention back in 2011 into reality in
2022
if permitted this development will
result in the intolerable levels of
congestion again a quote from the core
strategy that it was feared would occur
without a long-term strategic highway
solution
and nowhere is that more clearly
demonstrated than the ashton road hall
road junction which the parties are
referring to as junction 4.
there on the appellant's own figures in
the am peak in 2029 without the
development the average delay on the
ashington road approach would be 140
seconds per passenger car unit and the
average maximum queue would be 33
vehicles
the effect of the development would be
to increase this delay to 451 seconds
with an average maximum queue of 118
pcus
the appellant's bland admission that the
addition of development traffic will add
to delay and queuing
somewhat understates
the impact of a development that will
increase the delay on this key approach
by over two hundred percent
from two and a half minutes to seven and
a half minutes and increase the average
maximum q by 85 pcus and the position is
no better in the pm peak
and so i'm just going to pause there to
say that we'll hear a lot
no doubt about the modeling being
accepted
and we say that that's a distraction
from the real issue
of what those models even on the
appellants case actually show
and you'll note that there's been no
reference so far to the real world
impacts at that roundabout
in terms of delays and cues from the
appellant
it's a key point
also very important is the fact that
there's nothing that can be done about
it
junction 4 and i'm just going to call it
junction 4 from now on because that's
what all the proofs refer to junction 4
has already been improved
since the core strategy was adopted and
it's recognized by all parties that
there's no scope for further improvement
and all of that is on the appellant's
own most up-to-date figures
in the course of the appeal mr blair has
tweaked the modelling inputs in the
original transport assessment and its
addendum although all in one direction
in particular he's adjusted the
temporary growth rates and the vehicular
trip rates originally adopted resulting
in an improvement in junction capacity
compared to the previous position
the council has accepted that this is
acceptable
but it's also no part of mr blair's
evidence to say that the approach
adopted by his colleagues in the
original ta or taa was wrong or
unreasonable
therefore the reasonable range of impact
at junction 4 could extend based on the
figures presented to the planning
committee originally to a delay of
almost nine minutes on the washington
road approach and an average maximum
queue of 137
pcus
the appellant's answer to all of this is
to say people will adjust their behavior
by taking alternative modes of transport
alternative routes or journey times
this is an exercise in wishful thinking
alternative routes are limited and work
and education commitments limit the
flexibility of moving journey times the
appellant's travel plan target even if
realised will only result in a small
reduction in trips in the critical peak
hours
limited weight should be given to all of
these inherently uncertain factors
whether or not they have any effect will
only be known after it's too late and
the effect will be felt by the residents
of rochford long after this inquiry has
concluded
finally it's anticipated rightly having
had the appendage opening that a
repeated refrain from the appellant will
be the fact that essex county council as
highway authority considered that the
development was acceptable
however the question of severity is one
of judgment there are no thresholds that
must be crossed
and it's a judgment that paragraph 111
of the mppf entrusts on the local
planning authority in the first instance
and now you sir and not the highway
authority
plainly you'll rightly give the views of
ecc great weight i'm not going to say
otherwise however its judgment as with
any organization is not infallible and
nor can it be tested at this inquiry
ultimately mr bear's latest model
outcomes are common ground but they also
speak for themselves
the issue now is simply to reach the
judgment on whether or not those
outcomes are acceptable and likely to
change or not that judgment's for you
guided not only by the way that should
be given to ecc's opinion but also the
real life not modelled opinions of local
residents and their representatives who
experience the reality of traffic in
rochford on a daily basis
moving beyond congestion
the council's works proactively with the
appellant to narrow the range of issues
in dispute of this inquiry
a concern about pedestrian safety has
been resolved following pedestrian
survey information provided
to the council's consultants on the 7th
of january
in terms of in light of the terms of the
section 106 agreement the council no
longer raises an issue with the
provision of on-site parking spaces for
school drop-off and collection and it's
also accepted following the pedestrian
survey information that the reduction in
the width of the pavement outside hulk
farm infant school is not unacceptable
but and it's important but the council
agrees with ecc that it would be a
significant downgrade from what's
already in place and is therefore
undesirable from an education and public
health perspective
that's a quote from their consultation
response
significant remodeling work has been
done by the parties in respect to the
ashington road daleks road junction
junction free
it's now agreed that the initial
modeling presented to the planning
committee did not take into account the
effects of unequal lane usage on the
approach to the ashington road
that meant that even with mr blair's
adjustments to the original taa and the
proposed mitigation of the originally
proposed mitigation the junction would
be overloaded in 2029 resulting in
queues on that approach 79 pcu and a
delay of over four and a half minutes
the planning committee had been told
that the junction would operate within
theoretical capacity and that there
would be an improvement
to the baseline position in 2029
late last wednesday afternoon half an
hour before rebuttal throughs were due
mr flexman was made aware of the fact
that mr blair had designed an
alternative mitigation strategy for this
junction
in short the alternative mitigation
proposed reverts back to a single larger
single lane approach
mr flexman's content that this new
mitigation is deliverable and would
adequately mitigate the impact of the
development to an acceptable degree in
accordance with paragraph 111 of the
mppf resolving his concerns and so just
pick up there the point
made by mr foster um quite rightly it's
important that i clarify that
um the statement of common ground
highway statement common ground two
we're calling it
is signed by mr flexman
and
i've just seen the letterings off what
should be letter d
that is is b
um sorry sorry say that again i didn't
follow that bit sorry i'm just looking
at it it's got letters on the second
page a b c and then it reverts back to b
for some reason all right i've i've not
got a hard copy of that yeah i've seen
an emailed copy but not a hard copy i'll
just say what it says it says mr flexman
accepts that the residual cumulative
impacts on the highway network would not
be severe
so that's this records mr flexman's
professional opinion
it does not reflect the council's case
you've heard
already what the council's case is
and that will be presented through
councillor eves so i hope that that
clears that up
um
where was i
just bear with me
yeah okay uh paragraph 11.
finally at the rectory road washington
road junction uh what we call junction
one the appellant proposes effectively
reintroducing a two-lane entry to the
roundabout from victory road as council
eves will explain previous informal
two-lane entry was removed due to safety
concerns its reintroduction will also be
safe
and so sorry to
to jump off but there was a reference
earlier in miss reed's opening to
highway safety concerns relating
um to the council's case being
um no longer pursued so i just
well
they are being pursued and they're in mr
eve's proof and the reference to the
the first highway statement of common
ground excludes that point about rectory
road junction so just to
clear that up
sorry say that last bit again make sure
i've got a note of that so it paragraph
2.1
of the first the january the 1st january
2022 highway state and common ground
refers to
um
point c of our statement of case
that said rectory road washington road
was previously wired into two lanes but
was reduced back to one lane due to
highway safety concerns
and then it says that point is still
being pursued by rdc
okay
um turning then and finally to the
overall planning balance delivering
market and affordable housing on an
allocated site has obvious benefits in
the planning balance
and so
i'll take you to it through council
ashore but the council has agreed that
the benefit of new market housing should
be given significant weight
and the benefit of affordable housing
very significant weight and we don't shy
away from those benefits of the scheme
but
and it's important but
in returning to the the text the
paragraph 12 for the opening the fact
that this site is allocated does not
mean that any level of harm it causes
has been deemed to be acceptable
and the general imperative to boost
housing land supply is not a blank check
the mppf does not seek housing at any
cost and on the contrary it tells us to
refuse permission for unsafe development
and development that results in a severe
residual accumulative effect on the road
and i just add there
that
the council's
plan takes the same approach
a development that results in a severe
impact on the highway network would not
be plan lead
then finally the appellant's built much
ink in its highways and planning
evidence complaining about the way in
which the original planning application
was determined and criticisms of the
manushi of the council's actions during
the appeal process
we don't propose to take up substantive
inquiry time addressing those complaints
whether they're well-founded or not they
have nothing whatsoever to do with the
merits of the appeal and this is
ultimately an appeal about the impact of
this development on the local highway
network that's where the focus of
attention should be and that's where
residents want it to be and it's where
the council will direct its time and
evidence
in the end this is a simple appeal the
residual cumulative impact of the
development on the local highway network
would be severe and in any event the
mitigation proposed to even get to that
severe residual impact is unsafe
and for those reasons it fails the
relevant tests in local and national
policy and in due course we'll ask you
sir to dismiss the appeal
okay thank you mr parkinson thank you
thank you
so um mr foster i have uh
have you got a i see it's coming to me
now thank you
all right thanks sir um
just before actually uh presenting my
opening i just observed that we didn't
realize that the
opening speeches were 25 minute long
presentations of evidence we will be
delivering our evidence
in that section of the um
of the inquiry
and i assume having delivered evidence
misread probably won't need to speak
again
um
i'd reiterate that the not severe
statement that we received late last
night
as i understand it was signed without
the agreement of either officers or
elected members of the council
right so i'll go on now to my
introductory speech
um
[Music]
right thank you
i didn't in some of the evidence
submissions explain my background but it
was questioned in earlier days by the
appellant so
i trained in engineering for four years
as part of a
engineering cadet program in the
merchant navy
i have an honours degree in business
studies i'm a fellow of the royal
society
for the encouragement of arts
manufacturing and commerce
i will add for clarity that i'm also an
elected
for the ward where this development
proposed development is though this
evening this afternoon and so on i'm not
speaking as a counsellor or a
representative of the council
i've worked in the uk
europe and u.s motor industries for 38
years the last 16 years of which i was
responsible for the planning and
logistics
of material supply to assembly plants in
the uk belgium germany spain
portugal and russia
we were building some fifteen thousand
vehicles a day
i know the responsibility for more than
a thousand staff across those countries
but most importantly of all
i've lived in rochford for 40 years
and i've got fast first-hand experience
of the road traffic issues in this area
an amateur i'm proud to be speaking in
the inquiry on behalf of the rochester
supporters group
i'd also like to place on record and
thanks to the rocha district council
development committee for taking the
brave but correct decision to reject the
law application in full
i'd like to quote briefly from a long
letter which was actually from me
published in the local paper
and it said
a very small extract from a long letter
it said
to anyone living in rochford
particularly the ashland road area the
environment is awful
that letter was 30 years ago
in response to an essex county council
proposal to build a rochford bypass
after they'd done an extensive study of
the traffic flows and researching into
predicted traffic growth in the future
as i said that was 30 years ago
the bypass never happened i never quite
understood why
but essex were right about the need
housing development has been continuous
since that date
with major developments in the ashingdon
hawkwell hockley rockford areas plus of
course hulbridge and canoedon
all of which feed traffic into the
network of which ashkenan road is a
significant and highly congested part
people agreed then and still do about
infrastructure being a prerequisite for
development 30 years on
the infrastructure changes to the ashton
road
down through to rochford sutton road and
walnuts bridge have been a couple of
tweaks
as we go through our evidence
against the appeal we will demonstrate
that the tweaks to many roundabouts are
insignificant indeed irrelevant
and that the proposed development fails
to deliver the ser 8 policy requirement
for increased highway capacity
and also fails to comply with the nppr
policy requirement
for considering the cumulative impact of
development in nearby areas
i briefly like to move on to talk about
the statement of common ground process
a couple of weeks ago i listened to a
podcast by the king's chambers
a group of people who nicknamed
themselves the burritos if i heard it
correctly and that included miss reed
all right yeah
um
they were discussing the subject of how
to be successful in appeals
they particularly highlighted the
importance in the appeal process of the
statement of common ground
so
i'd like to update you sir on our
rochford supporters group experience in
relation to the statement of common
ground
on the 6th of december
sorry i missed a bit you recall the
target when we had the case management
conference
that the all the uh statements of common
ground will be completed by the 10th of
december
and as noted in the
conference minutes i'd like to share
with you the chronology of the
subsequent exchanges involving our
rochford supporters group
statements of common ground
on the 6th of december emory submitted a
proposed bloor rochford supporters group
statement of common ground
we replied on the 8th of december with
lots of suggested
but i hasten to add factual changes
both agreements and areas of
disagreement
on the 9th of december mr gascoigne
advised that they would respond in the
next day or so
and an extension was granted
it was actually on the 17th of december
when that updated version was received
from mr gascoigne in which he advised
that he would be on leave until january
the 4th
and mr pycroft would be dealing with it
in his absence
our comments had been pretty much
completely ignored
even though they were factual
i wrote to mr pycroff on the 18th of
december offering dates before christmas
to meet with him one to one via doom and
doom perhaps that's a
unfortunate slip of the tongue
before christmas freudian thank you
to make one to one via zoom
and to try to make progress
unfortunately in mr pycroft's note late
on the 23rd of december he apologized
for late response
due to vacation and other business
commitments
and asked that we instead respond with
tracked comments
in view of this we prepared a further
update to the statement of common ground
which we submitted on january the third
the day before mr pie craft was due back
from the christmas break
again i offered to meet one-to-one via
zoom to agree terms
there's been no response to that offer
to me nor has there been any response to
our updated statement of common ground
so why do i raise this now well first in
the king's chambers podcast they're made
big of the importance of the statement
of common ground
since the case management conference on
the 30th of november
those representing bloor have been
unstinting in their criticism of the
planning authority for any late response
including statement of common ground
i realize that we
the rochford supporters group whilst
large in membership
in terms of resources compared with law
and all their professional resource we
are small fish in a very large pond
however
the reaction to our input and offers to
meet has been nothing short of
contemptuous
not just to me as the amateur advocate
but chris austin and melanie english who
lead the group but also the 2 000 plus
people who support us the rockford
supporters group
so
whilst we the rockford supporters group
apologized to yourself in the inquiry
for not for there not being an agreed
statement of common ground between us
and the appellant
we did try to follow due process and
timing thank you sir i'm going to now
hand over to chris austin who's going to
add a few personal words
can i just check if have i also got
something written from mrs austin
um
[Music]
we will make well it still is still
going to be part of the opening
submissions for the rockford supporters
group isn't it we'll make coppers
immediately afterwards if that's okay
or we could take a five-minute break and
get coffee i i think if that's possible
i'd prefer that i always like things
before before it's said and then i i
know that i've got a copy of what is
said not something that's amended okay
thank you
okay well um how long will it take to
copy those
okay well
it's 11 42.
let's adjourn shorter german 1150 i'll
resume again at 11 50. thank you
okay
is
oh
just
justice
so
uh
all right
archer
hello
um
yes
so
can i ask you all to start resuming your
seats please
thank you
it is 11 50. so the inquiry is resumed
i realize it would have been better if
i'd have had a longer break there
because i
wanted to have a break after hearing
from the rochester supporters group a
proper mid-morning break to allow people
to uh get a drink but um we are where we
are so we'll i'll hear from mrs austin
and then we'll perhaps have another
short break ended up having two two
breaks this morning
this is austin when you're ready then
sir thank you for giving me the
opportunity to speak today
it is all too easy to get caught up in
the facts and figures the arguments and
the counter arguments and the david
versus goliath nature of this case
yet that removes the most single
important consideration
is this development right for rochford
and its residents
the answer as provided by the local
planning authority and supported by the
residents of rochford is a firm no
this is the wrong development in the
wrong place when melanie english and i
formed the rochester supporters group in
july 2019
we did so because we wanted to do the
right thing in the right way
unite our community cohere the concerns
of all to enable us to engage
collaboratively with the appropriate
authorities and exercise our right to
challenge this planning application
excuse me i'm out of breath
these have not been easy goals to
achieve whilst many supported us there
were others who wanted us to fail we
were tagged as bored housewives with a
nimby attitude who were getting in the
way it was assumed that we would get
bored and fall silent but we didn't
and we haven't let those who tried to do
their best to derail us stop us either
despite all the challenges we may have
been successful at last count more than
2 300 residents have joined our group
many wanted to speak today and others
ensured their voices were heard by
letters of objection
although it is my voice you hear today i
speak on behalf of them all
the sir eight was adopted into the local
plan back in 2012. we accept that
we have been robustly supported by the
right honourable mark francois mp
but our current leader councillor simon
wooten a gentleman overflowing with
honesty integrity and a commitment to do
the right thing for the town and the
residents he represents
agrees that the sitting planning
officers at that time made a mistake in
adopting it
this mistake is made even more obvious
if you consider how the community has
changed in the decades since its
acceptance
but today together we can correct that
mistake and make a positive difference
to the lives of all rochford residents
and not allow that mistake to be
exploited by the appellant
what of the david vs goliath analogy i
mentioned earlier well that is how we
feel
goliath or in this case the appellant
appears to have the power they have
colossal finances to pay for a
remarkable legal team
and expert witnesses
they have funded the production of reams
of reports and statistics to confuse
obfuscate and twist the reality we live
daily and they have provided computer
modelling for transport and highway
assessments
but that modelling is only as good as
the information fed into it and it can
be easily manipulated to produce the
desired results
i am confident that if i had the money
to pay for similar modelling it would
produce results agreeing with the
assertions of the rochester supporters
group
and we the supporters group are david we
do not have the money or the teams of
professionals to support us but we do
have our integrity and the immense
support of the community we represent
we have followed the rules been fair and
done the right thing
supported by the brilliant ian foster we
have collated
irrefutable evidence demonstrating
statistics put forward by the appellant
are not reliable
we can prove the ashington road is
already unable to cope with the amount
of traffic flowing all day every day not
just during the school run or during
morning and evening rush hour it is
caused by the sheer
volume of traffic on what is a narrow
road and this is made worse by
unavoidable obstacles and narrowing
which slows the flow of traffic
thursday bin day the ambulan roundabout
and any number of other daily events
that cause traffic to slow and congest
and the reality is that we all know the
proposed development would necessarily
worsen all these issues with because
with more houses come more people and
with more people come more cars
which automatically leads to more road
users more congestion and more pollution
and that isn't the end of the bad news
for the development would also increase
the risk to every child attending to
hulk farm junior and infant schools
i am not alone in saying this the county
public health and education department
said and i quote
the applicant appears to have
prioritized securing a means of
vehicular access into the proposed site
over the potential impact on holt farm
junior and infant schools this
application cannot be supported by ecc
in respect of education and public
health
it's a scary idea isn't it
reduce the hulk farm primary school
footpath by nearly 50 percent
widen the carriageway and force the
children to seek refuge in the middle
of a very busy road whilst trying to
cross it and let's be clear these aren't
just anonymous children that we are
referring to here they are our children
our grandchildren they are also our
future and they must get to school
safely
perhaps rather than just talk problems
we should look for solutions a new
relief road would be
would ease some of the easily
foreseeable problems and could be an
acceptable solution but essex highways
haven't found a location for the road
acquired as there is an absolute lack of
space for it
nor have they found any solution to the
current problems so i fear talk of a new
road doesn't help anyone
the developer could make a 106 financial
contribution but that doesn't provide an
answer because it doesn't address the
root cause of the problem so that isn't
a solution either
therefore in the absence of other
options we need to look back to the
answer already provided by the local
planning authority which is
it will be a dreadful mistake
i'm paraphrasing a little but maybe the
best way to not make existing problems
worse and to avoid creating new problems
is to not
squeeze more people and cars
into a space they simply cannot fit
or in other words refuse this
application
yet history tells tells us a whopping 80
percent of developer developer appeals
are one
questionable odds to say the least
however i believe our evidence related
to this development is as strong today
as it was when the application was
initially refused we must not ignore the
fact that housing developers are not
always right
just because something can be built
doesn't mean it should be
and we must also not ignore the fact
that the local population is not always
wrong
in their objections the residents know
their area better than anyone else
when this many come together to say that
something is wrong their voice must not
only be listened to but heard as well
margaret thatcher once said watch your
thoughts for they will become actions
watch your actions for they will become
habits
what's your habits for they will forge
your character what's your character for
it will forge your destiny
and that sir leads me to the question i
wish to ask you as i close my comments
today
is it your destiny to condemn thousands
of roch
residents to years of misery during this
construction of this development
followed by even greater misery once the
houses are built or is it your destiny
to connect correct the mistake of the
2012 local plan and condemn this
unacceptable
planning application to history
and lastly i will not be giving up my
car and using another form of transport
thank you
[Applause]
okay thank you mrs austin
so that concludes the opening
submissions for the
three main parties um
now as i say had i have really been on
the ball a few minutes ago i would have
had a longer break so we could have had
a reasonable mid-morning break i'm
i'm reluctant and unless people are
desperate for a comfort break to
actually have a further break now
because i see time is going on i know mr
francoise wants to to make his uh his
statement so unless anyone's desperate
that we have a further break
no
okay
mr francoise then would you like to come
to the
witness stand and give me your your
statement
so just just while mr francois is
setting himself in there um i've got a
copy here because i know you mentioned a
moment ago you didn't have this of the
second statement of common ground yeah i
haven't got that yet let me let me have
that
bear with me a moment mr francoise i'll
put
okay thank you
sorry sir is is this a statement that's
been served already because i don't have
a copy of it
one that i broke yesterday because i was
told that my original one was too long
so i had to cut it down to save time it
is yes objection i was just checking
because i haven't got a copy on my desk
yes so so what have i what have i got
here mr franz parsons just so
if if i've got a different version to
what you had previously then again it
would be helpful if the other main
parties work today explain
at the case management conference plea
please sit mr francoise i mean you you
may be used to standing uh
you know where i work sir we speak
standing up yeah i mean i'll say yeah i
i would prefer yes
thank you
when i produced this is your microphone
on
when i produced my written statement i
was advised by your
client
that that would take too long to read
out i thought it would take half an hour
and i was advised and that would be too
long so i was asked to cut that down to
something nearer to
20 to 25 minutes
so what i've got is a cut down version
of what i gave him in writing on the
23rd it's not exactly the same because
prefers it shorter because that's what i
was asked to do
well that is helpful as far as it goes
mr franz was but as i say though the
problem is uh mike
the the other main parties don't have a
copy of what you're now going to be
reading out i'm sure they can listen sir
they can listen but in terms of taking
notes that that's the whole point there
um with respect to i wasn't asked to
bring multiple copies
well um mr francois have you asked me to
do that if they had i would have done
had it been submitted in advance then
the council would have copied it and
circulated it that's that's the normal
form
just one second oliver
[Music]
okay
that's fine thank you
it seems to be now i i'm certainly
content with that and mr parkinson said
he's happy to continue
thanks
in that case
mr inspector councillors ladies and
gentlemen i'm very grateful for an
opportunity as the local member of
parliament for raleigh and whitford in
whose constituency the appeals site is
located
to make a personal contribution to these
proceedings today
i've been a member of parliament for
over 20 years now i'm a former minister
of state
in both the ministry of defence and what
was at that time
the department for communities and local
government and i was also appointed as a
privy councillor in 2010.
turning to the application the national
planning policy framework the nppf
against which this application must be
judged
unfortunately does not provide a clear
definition of what constitutes a severe
traffic effect
it says only apparel 111 of the 2021
edition that and i quote
development should only be prevented or
refused on highways grounds if there
would be an unacceptable impact on
highway safety or the residual
cumulative impacts on the road network
would be severe
a direct example of the difficulty this
creates is on thursday the 5th of
november 2020 accompanied by a number of
senior rockford district council
councillors and rdc planning officers
i participated in a virtual meeting with
essex county council highways officers
to discuss the traffic implications of
the original homes planning application
during our discussion
ecc highways officers conceded that some
of the key junctions along the ashington
road were in their words already swamped
and that they would become worse by 2029
the end of the traffic analysis period
for the purposes of this application
however
they also admitted that they could not
practically object to the application on
highways grounds
because
they could only do so if the traffic
effect was deemed severe
and yet this was undefined in the mppf
and no other authoritative definition of
what constituted a severe effect existed
therefore in their view
with no clear metrics to guide them
the definition of what constituted a
severe effect was in their words
entirely subjective
which made it very difficult to object
to the application itself
therefore
the fact that ecc highways as the local
highways authority did not object to the
application which the appellants seek to
make much of has to be seen very clearly
in this context they didn't object
because they believed that they couldn't
we turn now to the number of vehicles on
the proposed development site the
appellant's own transport assessment
states that each two-bedroom property or
larger will have at least two parking
spaces indeed for larger what i might
call executive style homes of which a
considerable number are proposed for the
estate there could be three or even more
cars per family
the transport assessment estimated 512
parking spaces for the 223 drillings on
phase one of the estate which comprises
almost exactly a third of the 662 total
so there's an extra extrapolated pro
rata for phases two and three this then
envisages some 1
500 vehicles or more
being based on the estate once it is
built out
the idea that so many extra vehicles the
bulk of which would be leaving and then
returning to the estate during the
morning and evening peak period would
have only a very marginal effect on
local traffic flows is clearly
implausible
for instance
the appellant traffic assessment assumes
that in the morning peak between eight
to nine am only 167 additional vehicles
from the new development will transit
the already congested ashenton road
daley's road roach avenue junction in
other words
barely 11
1 in 10 of the likely vehicles on the
new estate will attempt to travel south
along that part of the ashingdon road in
the morning peak one in ten of them
that assertion flies in the face of all
common sense
then the entrance and exit to the site
the main proposed entry and exit point
is on the ashland road itself almost
almost directly opposite holt farm
infant and junior schools
at present part of the area between the
existing houses and the ashenton road is
occupied by what is in effect a large
lay-by which is regularly used by
parents to drop their children off at
either of the two schools opposite or in
some cases in teresa's catholic primary
school just a few hundred meters further
south along the ashiman road
this creates an extremely busy area each
morning and afternoon during the school
run
the appellant's proposals would
effectively deny this lay by to parents
completely
bloor offered to compensate by
allocating just 10
dedicated parking spaces close to the
proposed emergency vehicle entrance
rather than the main entrance itself the
emergency vehicle entrance is further
south
however their transport assessment
assumes that each of these 10 spaces
will only be used four times between
eight and nine am ie there will be forty
parking slots if you will to serve
children and parents from three schools
each of which has several hundred pupils
these revised arrangements designed in
part i believe to cram the maximum
number of dwellings onto the site are
patently unsafe
as they would almost certainly lead to
congestion and potentially even parking
rage amongst anxious parents
trying to utilize this highly limited
parking area whilst in many cases
seeking to avoid subsequently being late
for work
such a congested and potentially highly
charged situation is obviously
unsafe
we then have the shared space at
ashington road opposite the schools
there are similar concerns relating to
the footpath stroke cycle lane opposite
the two schools which is almost directly
opposite the main entrance exit point
for the proposed development
holt farm junior school lodged a very
direct objection as quoted in the report
to the 24th june 2021 development
control committee which turned down the
application holt farm junior school's
objection read i quote
our objection specifically relates to
the position of the access to the site
being directly opposite the schools holt
farm junior school and holt farm infant
school and the lack of consideration of
alternative options providing safer
access to the site further along
ashington road
as the school's objection then
powerfully continues i quote again from
the same report
the proposed site access specifically
removes a cycle path and narrows the
pavement in front of our site
we believe this will have an extremely
detrimental effect
on the safety of our pupils and parents
attending the schools which have overall
people numbers of 600 plus
an extremely detrimental effect on the
safety of our pupils and parents
the site access also comprises the
access to the shared car park for both
schools so i'm continuing their quote
the site access also
compromises the access to the shared car
park for both schools which is already
located very close to a busy road with
an unmanned pelican crossing giving us
further safety concerns for this
proposal for both our staff parents and
pupils we believe that there are
alternative sites for access to
development that have not been explored
simply due to financial implications
which is unacceptable considering the
overall infrastructure pressures in
rockford in particular along the
ashingdon road
moreover
the undesirability of this approach is
highlighted in the mppf itself sir at
para 112c
which states the applications for
development should and i quote from the
mppf
create places that are safe secure and
attractive which minimize the scope for
conflicts between pedestrians cyclists
and vehicles avoid unnecessary street
clutter and respond to local character
and design standards
clearly forcing infant school children
and cyclists into a narrow shared space
during a sometimes frenetic school run
on a weekday morning or afternoon simply
in order to accommodate the new entry
exit for the development across a very
busy road is by any common sense measure
not a wise or indeed a safe thing to do
thus yet again
the application falls valving falls foul
of the unacceptable impact on highway
safety test in para 111 of the nppf
the real effect on the ashington road
the ashanda road is punctuated by a
number of key junctions along its
broadly north south axis the revised
traffic assessment still shows that the
theoretical and even practical capacity
of some of the key junctions along the
ashingdon road will be exceeded in 2029
unless the junctions are mitigated by
being physically redesigned remember sir
that in november 2020 ecc highways
officers candidly admitted that some of
these junctions were already swamped
that's now
without the houses
similarly the ashingdon road hall road
west street junction is also estimated
to exceed both its practical and
theoretical capacity by 2029 but in this
instance it cannot be mitigated by an
engineering solution because of its
physical geography including already
narrow approach lanes in some directions
and a railway bridge immediately nearby
i'm sure you noticed that sir when you
did your unannounced site visit
as a fallback law then resort to
reliance on a number of green travel
initiatives and imply that many of the
residents will instead conveniently
choose to walk or cycle to work rather
than drive
but with little confirming evidence base
to back up what is basically simply an
unsupported assertion
from experience
while my constituents are certainly
environmentally conscious
rocha with the street recycling
champions two years out of five sir
there is also a very strong car culture
in south essex which seems unlikely to
alter to anything like the degree
necessary to suit law's purposes
even if residents of the estate switch
to electric vehicles that might
admittedly reduce emissions but it would
do nothing to actually reduce the weight
of traffic itself the assertion is
therefore an effectively highly
subjective one moreover
given the already very slow moving
traffic along the ashley road in the
morning peak generating considerable
emissions as a result it is not likely
to prove a popular regular walking route
for pedestrians
the appellants are then reduced to even
falling back on the handy assertion that
people would simply decide to travel at
different times outside of the peak to
reduce traffic flows
this entirely speculative assertion of
course
assumes that their work or study
commitments will permit this which in
many cases they may not
similarly the pandemic and working from
home is not a practical alleviation as
the traffic assessments have to endure
up to 2029
so any temporary changes in work
patterns resulting from covert 19 cannot
reliably be assumed to endure for a
further decade it is quite simply too
early to tell
but it gets worse
the appellants and their consultants
blithely assert that drivers may take
alternative routes in an area with an
already highly congested and constrained
local road network but without providing
any convincing details on what these
alternative routes might actually be
what precise alternative route would
they take
that would be any more advantageous than
the direct option of cueing in very slow
moving traffic along the ascendant road
in either direction
again
the unsubstantiated assertions which
accompanies bloors traffic assistance or
not convincing or as the military would
say they're not ground truth compliant
they're merely wishful thinking worthy
of charles dickens's mr micawber
in summary my case against the
appellants can be collated under a
number of key headings
firstly frequent road works and i
referred to this more in my written
submission of december
the ashni road is subject to frequent
roadworks which only make traffic
congestion worse
indeed when i carried out my own recce
of the site opposite the two schools
last friday morning there was a
contraflow in place barely a hundred
metres south of the two holt farm
schools as contractors were yet again
digging up the roads and causing
congestion hardly any of which appears
in the appellant's deliberately benign
computer modelling
alternative routes
the appellants themselves concede that
both the theoretical and practical
capacity of the ashington road west
street hall road junction will be
exceeded by 2029 and the physical
mitigation is impossible they fall back
on green travel plans which are in some
cases temporary there'll be bus passes
for a year or so wholly unconvincing and
clearly not evidenced in addition they
argue that car commuters will
conveniently stagger their journeys
without any convincing evidence for this
similarly they suggest that many drivers
will use alternative routes which
without identifying which actual routes
they're referring to
even though these would have to include
options which are part of an already
heavily congested local highways network
i positively look forward sir
to being cross-examined by miss reed on
which actual in the real world
alternative routes the appellants have
in mind
and if she doesn't want to cross-examine
me on that her silence will speak
volumes
severe traffic effect
essex county council by their own
highways by the essex county council
highways by their own admission did not
object to this application as they had
no reliable definition of a severe
traffic effect against which to judge it
it's not it is for the local planning
authority in this case rochford district
council to decide on what constitutes a
severe effect and not
the local highways authority in this
case essex county council on whose
judgment the appellants seek to largely
rest their case even though i've
established that highways said they
couldn't object anyway
just over a month ago i submitted a
freedom of information request to essex
county council highways asking how many
planning applications for which easy
highways was a statutory council t they
objected to in each of the last four
calendar years in both actual and
percentage terms
i'm yet to receive a response and if
necessary i'll go to the information
commissioner to obtain one but i suspect
that the answer will be very few indeed
for the reason already given the ecc
highways believe they have no practical
benchmark for what actually constitutes
a severe effect
when i get the answer sir i would like
to submit it to you however
we do have a recent precedent in a
similar case in november 2021 the
secretary of state michael gove mp
upheld the decision by a planning
inspector mrs j vice to reject an appeal
against medway council in kent's
decision to refuse an application for a
major housing development in raynham
presumably on the grounds of the
development will create a severe effect
on local traffic
the decision letter of the 3rd of
december 21 clearly states and i quote
overall on highway matters the secretary
of state agrees with the inspector your
counterpart that the appeals scheme
would have a severe residual cumulative
impact on the local highway network
and that there would be conflict in this
regard with local planned policy t1 and
paragraphs 110 and 111 of the framework
the secretary of state considers this
harm attracts substantial weight against
the appeal scheme end quote
so less than three months ago the
secretary of state upheld an inspector's
decision to reject an appeal largely on
the grounds of a severe traffic effect
on the local highway network
i'm not resting my whole case on this
sir but this is nevertheless both a
recent and relevant precedent which i
would like to highlight to you
safety
the proposed mitigation of the
retro-road ashandar road junction at
golden cross by widening the approach
from one lane to two is clearly unsafe
as essex county council highways
themselves reversed exactly this action
a few years ago on the safety grounds
which is clearly at odds with para 111
of the mppf essex county council
deliberately did the opposite of what
law now claim is safe
in addition the effective lost
appearance of the lay-by opposite both
schools and its replacement by only 10
parking spaces providing by the
appellant's own estimates only 40
parking slots in both the morning and
afternoon peak is potentially a recipe
for parking confusion or worse and thus
contradicts the safety injunction
inherent in para 111 of the mppf as well
moreover
the creation of a narrow non-delineated
shared space for cyclists and primary
and even infant school children on the
pathway directly in front of the two
holt farm schools is inherently
dangerous
this concerned ecc's education
department and the schools themselves as
they evidenced in writing i said more
about that in my written submission
earlier
the reduction of this space from six
meters to three is clearly dangerous and
is also contrary to parallel 112
of the mppf as well as finding the
safety test inherent in the preceding
para 111
it is simply unacceptable to put young
children at syria at risk of injury in
this way for profit
or indeed for any other reason sir
overall the appellant's case today is
highly contrived and wholly unconvincing
to anyone with even a basic knowledge of
the rockford district's local highway
network their case is largely based on
distant abstract computer modelling
rather than ground truth actual
experience
and even the appellants themselves admit
they have changed the assumptions that
were fed into the original computer
model presumably because they got the
first they got the wrong ask the first
time around as the old saying about
computers has it sir junking junk out
finally ladies and gentlemen
the effect of the considerable
additional traffic which is likely to be
generated by an additional
662 dwellings
many of which will host multiple
vehicles an already very congested road
renowned for roadworks and with an
entrance opposite a highly dangerous
proposed share space which will pitch
cyclists against school children
directly opposite and outside an infant
and junior school fails on sheer common
sense grounds right from the outset
the real world effect of these proposals
is likely to be severe at best and
highly dangerous at worst and thus the
appendance case should be
comprehensively a direct rejected on
both traffic severity and safety grounds
as the local member of parliament for 20
years i rest my case
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i i have said already that applause
isn't appropriate i know feelings are
running high please try and desist
um mr francois thank you for that i've
got uh
i've got uh a separate sheet here i'm
not quite sure what i what i do with
that that that was a copy of what you've
read right sir when it was passed to me
there was this as well is this something
i need to be aware of yes what i've done
sir is in the in my evidence
i refer to
a virtual meeting that took place
on the 5th of november 2020
with
myself counselors and officers of
rochford and also essex county council
highways offices right
so i've included for you a copy of my
contemporaries
contemporaneous handwritten note of that
meeting to back up
the assertion that i've or the point
that i've made in my evidence that
counties said they couldn't object
because they had no definition of severe
i understand so that in effect that's
that's uh a further written submission
so it's the backup
it's to back up essentially my statement
yes yes yes
did you receive a copy of that misread
no sir um i don't need one immediately
so if
if a copy could perhaps be made
available by the council for us yes yeah
we can do that so yeah okay that's good
thank you right so let me just get my
papers in order there just on that i
don't know
um we've got a copy of fiverr so if it
would be possible to to get that before
we go so i handed mine over i think the
copy i think the photocopier at work can
stretch to two okay yeah pretend yeah
mr foster i don't know i mean it would
be not normally the case that obviously
each of the main parties has copies of
all the documentation so that they can
refer to it if need be so
so yes three three copies in total
needed the other thing it was
referencing people decisions i don't
know if that was attached to the
submission but if it was it'd be helpful
to have that no no i didn't i didn't
attach all of that but but i
uh and the reason sir i didn't reference
that appeal in my original note in
december of the 23rd
was because i only became a very aware
of that appeal decision post facto
okay
so
the secretary of state i believe the
inspectors report was dated july 21
and the secretary of state's decision
letter was november well it it
yes
i mean clearly it's going to be
available um
it's on the department's website yes if
if obviously you've given me an extract
from it um
it would be helpful to have the whole
sounds that was a secretary of state
case from what you've said there
the
inspector's report is 200 pages long yes
but i'm glad so and that's all on online
but i'll gladly get you a copy of the
secretary of state's decision later
which you know about six pages yes i've
got a copy here maybe i can we can talk
outside i couldn't work out could you do
the photocopying for that yeah we we we
won't delay
too much now but yes clearly an extract
there be helpful to have it in context
so it's just that um
given that it's a secretary of state
decision i appreciate the length of the
inspector's report behind it but sir i
respectfully suggest that if you are
accepting it and we don't object to you
doing so it also includes the
inspector's report so that you have the
context of the
secretary of state's decision because
obviously at points secretary of state
will say for example paragraphs x y
yes yes yes i i have to have both to
make sense of the secretary of state's
decision letter because secretary of
state will refer as you say to a range
of paragraphs in the inspector's report
that he agrees with or disagrees with so
i'm not i'm not hanging my whole case on
it but i do think it's a very relevant
recent press of course i don't
understand that but you know
equally you've made reference to it
therefore it's only right
that i have the ability and the other
parties do to actually look through it
and
see to take it more in context i think
that's the thing
okay so
though those documents will be provided
so thank you mr francoise um
miss reed have you got some questions
that you want to put to france
listen very carefully to mr francoise mp
my practice with third parties is to
listen carefully take a note and to pick
issues up with my expert in examination
in chief which i've got a relatively
lengthy time estimate for examination in
chief with my expert
so i'm going to proceed on that basis
thank you very much i'm so sorry you
don't want to ask me any questions at
all no thank you i spent months
preparing for this
so
well that's
when mr france was
you you've given your evidence i've got
your evidence
miss reed has explained what her
practice is with third party witnesses i
i may have some questions for you but
miss reed's made it clear that the
points that you've raised she will pick
up with her
witnesses and at least ask me about the
alternative reads come on
so may we make a small point when miss
reed is speaking she keeps turning away
from the microphone and we can't hear
what she's saying
i'm going to just move it there so that
when i'm addressing the inspector i'm
speaking into the microphone i'm so
sorry i moved it for when i was
delivering the opening yeah microphones
are the the bane of uh
witnesses and advocates at public
inquiry so it's certainly not uncommon
but yes i think that might be the best
move there
okay so there's nothing that you want to
put to mr francoise let me let me look
through your original statement mr
francoise because there were a few
things on well one can i just ask you
here
yes on the
the statement that you've read out now
yes sir on your
uh
in effect your paragraphs seven and
eight
just bear with me i was making loads of
my own questions here
this is about the number of vehicles on
the site it is yes
yes what what you're saying there you're
telling me
um your pro rata estimate of vehicles
parked on the site if the site was
developed for the full 662. not
precisely sir it's a it's a remember
uh the development is in three phases
and the application was an outline for
the whole development but detailed for
phase one yeah so we know the number
these are not the number of vehicles
these are not the number of parking
spaces yes and in phase one because it
was a detailed application the appellant
actually went into that
specified down to that level of detail
if you'll forgive me
so as it's almost exactly one-third of
the number of dwellings i've done a
simple pro rata calculation that it will
be much the same for the other two yep
yep
happy with that sorry just to clarify
these are parking spaces it could well
be as anyone who lives no around here
knows there'll probably be more cars
than parking spaces
yeah i mean just as a simple example you
know a lot of families now let's say
they have someone aged 17 or 18
in my day those people would have walked
to college now they drive
so it's not uncommon you know to have
three or four cars or more in quotes and
executive style homes so if anything
1500 is an underestimate rather than an
over estimate and then sorry sorry
executive style homes what are you
saying there what i mean is sorry i
should explain that
so you've got a variety of number you've
got a variety of different sized homes
on the state
we only know the precise numbers for
phase one
sometimes developers refer to the larger
properties as executive style homes
it's just a phrase in the in the in the
development industry
but
uh and i'm saying for some of those
homes you may have even more but
the appellant's own transport assessment
estimated that even each two-bedroom
property
or larger would have at least two
parking spaces
yeah okay
hence 512 for 223 times three takes you
to over 1500 yeah yeah it's more your
power eight i want to get on to because
what i want to know is
where where your what what your estimate
would be you you you say here that 167
additional vehicles um i think you say
we'll transit the already congested
ashington road daley's road
roach avenue so so this is
167 southbound yes it's in the morning
that was from the peninsula okay so so
what what i
want you to tell me if you can is is
what your estimate is instead of the 167
and i accept that you may not be able to
do that
but but
be assured i'm i'm going to want to know
from the appellants
where the traffic generation figures
come from yes and so it'd be nice to
know in in what sense you're telling me
this flies in the face of common sense
well sir let me try and put it this way
you've got an estate with around 1500
vehicles on it
it may be more but let's say 1500 for
the purposes of debate
a lot of those people are either going
to go to work or they're going to go to
school or college
and that means they're probably going to
leave in the morning and the evening
peak i mean why do we have a morning and
an evening peak why do we have a rush
hour it's because that's when most
people travel
so i'm just saying that i think it is
completely fanciful that of those
fifteen hundred vehicles
only 167
will travel south along the ascendant
road in the morning peak now i could if
you want me to
to put a finger in the air and put a
number on it i'd say it's probably at
least two or three times that
i mean if you just apply as it were
common sense part of the the problem in
this whole
thing
is that the appellants rely on abstract
computer modelling
now
i think that and again as they've
already admitted
they changed the assumptions between two
different models they did one transport
assessment with one set of assumptions
when that didn't give them the answer
they wanted
they changed the assumptions but these
are all theoretical computer models they
bear very little relationship to what
goes on in real life
so just think about it
fifteen hundred vehicles on that estate
do you really believe so in your heart
of hearts it's credible that only one in
ten of those vehicles will head south in
the morning rush hour of course not and
then the appellants say well they'll use
alternative routes i mean that's
fundamental to the mitigation
of the hall road west street junction
you can't physically mitigate it because
it's next to a whopping great railway
bridge
and i think in their evidence the
rockford supporters will provide some
photographs of what that junction is
really like but i'll leave that to mr
foster he's more than capable of
speaking for himself but my point sir is
this
that junction is already swamped you
can't physically mitigate it you're
going to throw all this extra traffic at
it
and so the transport consultants fall
back on the fact
that don't worry people will take
alternative routes
and that's their mitigation so my
question is which alternative because
they can't answer the question they
can't mitigate the junction
and so their case falls
under para111
it must be a severe effect if an already
swamped junction is going to be even
more swamped so forgive me for being
dogmatic about it but this is
fundamental to the case
what are the alternative routes yep i i
understand your point yeah
okay
um
why doesn't miss me want to ask me any
questions sir
well i'm i'm i'm checking
um if there's any questions i need to
ask you on the evidence i i congratulate
you i'm told you're about to take silk
well done so if you're going to be a qc
please ask me something
mr francoise
there's no there's no need for this
there's no there's no need for this all
right so what's your next one
i've explained just to reiterate i've
explained that with third parties it is
my practice
to listen carefully and respectfully
take a careful and detailed note
and to take those points with my expert
in examination in chief and unless i've
got points of clarification that is the
practice that i will be adopting with mr
francoise mp and with other third
parties in this inquiry as i always do
yes thank you miss reed it's it's
certainly a practice that i've
encountered with other advocates so it's
nothing
special to this inquiry that's fine sir
i just wish i'd known that in advance
that's
that's by the by i think what i need to
do is just make sure having gone through
your evidence whether there was anything
more yes i think or anything where i
think on your original
statement which which clearly what
you've read out today is uh a
paraphrasing of that's what i was asked
to do yeah no that's fine so i mean on
your original one i'd i'd you you'd
refer to executive style houses so i've
asked you no hopefully we've clarified
i've also um
made a note to ask you on what basis do
you say that the traffic generation was
um dubious or for whatever whatever word
you prefer to use so i'm just checking
so these are things that i'd already
noted i needed to ask you about
um
another one here which is
well it's
it's the
it was your original paragraph 31 which
you gave
this was the shared space at the schools
and you gave a quote from
the ecc consultation response was that
my my december submission power 31 it
was yes
sorry i'm just checking you you did say
the same today i was just trying to get
my bearings as to where it was
sorry so
for clarity
uh power 31 in my december submission
yep
was from a quote was from a corporate
response from ethics county council
because
when essex county council responded to
the application as a council team
it wasn't just a response from highways
it was a response from the council as a
whole yes and it's probably true to say
that the education department's response
was somewhat of variance with the
highways department's response remember
if your highways
and you've decided that you can't object
then you've got to make everything fit
that
the education department aren't bound by
the same parameter
so in their bit of the educate of the
collective response they said
and this is what i say at para 31
the applicant appears to prioritize
securing a means of vehicle access into
the site over the potential impact on
holt farm junior and infant school
through a reduction in the segregated
footpath and cycle lane which we do not
support so you're in the you're in the
slightly anomalous situation that one
part of county hall is supporting the
application or rather not objecting to
it and another part of county hall is
yes no i i i follow that i just wanted
to to um be clear and it may be
something that the um the the council's
witnesses are going to assist if you're
not able to but it really it was a case
of um the formal ecc position
um
overall on the application as uh put
forward to members in the um report to
committee that's what i want to know i i
fully fully understand
i mean i've looked myself at this but
it's nice to hear it from others just
the completeness in case i'm accused
sorry just i don't want to detain the
inquiry because i have to get back for
this committee on the ukraine but just
for completeness i don't want to be
accused of selected quoting
so at para 34
in my december submission sir
just a couple of apparent a few powers
down
it points out that in february 21 essex
county council produced a further
consultation response
which
referred to the proposed shared space as
follows so this obviously was subsequent
to the original i quote
we do not consider the proposal to
reduce the foot and cycle way outside
the school to be unacceptable provided
that it meets the minimum technical
standard for a shared or segregated area
however
as outlined in our initial corporate
response it would be a significant
downgrade
from what is already in place and is
therefore undesirable
from an education and public health
perspective now as a politician sir if
you'll forgive me
that looks to me
like the result of an internal debate
within county hall where highways wanted
education to tone down their objection
so education then produced this
which is still if you read between the
lines still an objection but without
being as bold as the one that they put
in a few months before if you see what
i'm saying so the education department
responsible for the school and the
safety of the parents and the pupils
think it isn't safe
and the highways department who right
from the word go decided they couldn't
object in the first place because they
didn't have a definition of severe
against which to judge as saying that it
is
yep i i you follow my argument
i i i follow the point you're making
certainly yes yes sir if it assists just
in terms of those documents councillor
shaw has included the full letters in
her evidence at appendix 2 and appendix
iv
right well i'm sure we'll get on to that
in due course thank you
i don't think mr francoise uh there's
any other points that i need to ask you
to either clarify or any questions that
i've got on your evidence so thank you
very much for your
contribution you may re-take your seat
and obviously you may
head off back now to uh
how's the parliament hopefully i won't
get caught in traffic sir thank you very
much okay
thank you thank you well with
with with 12 42
um
let me just check i think we'll we'll
try and
go on if that's okay until about one
o'clock then i'll break then so some of
you will obviously not be speaking until
after
lunch
just let me
turn back to my
list i think only one person indicated
they wanted to speak early when i asked
earlier on and that was
sarah jones
but then i subsequently had two people
let me just get this right so
helen wright would like to
speak sooner rather than later is that
right
today's
a big pun
how about how about this afternoon
saf news nothing
not a problem not a problem and and who
is the other person the gentleman there
so is it mr
mr dolby yes yes
yeah how you've not submitted anything
in writing have you yet
when did you
you've got copies to hand out yeah okay
um
sarah jones is it
mrs miss muzz
muzz
bear with me please
and have you submitted a statement
please
so so we've got that as well okay
well let me take
ms jones first
please
so
thank you
so
mrs jones would you come to the
microphone please there might be
a few delays while i shuffle bits of
paper here but
i think
we're okay
at the minute
um mr parkinson you've got a copy of ms
jones's statement ms reed have you also
got one okay
mr foster have you i'm just checking
that everyone's got one
you okay
in that case would you like to introduce
yourself to the inquiry and give me your
statement then please yeah my name is
sarah jones
i'll keep it short and sweet
um i just want to let you know the
impact that the ash indian road has on
my job as a community carer i've worked
as a community carer in rochford and
surrounding areas the last ten years
over the years the traffic and
congestion has gone from bad to worse
i care for the elderly and vulnerable
people in their own homes and these
people depend on us to get them up
washed dressed toileted and feed them
some of them have time sensitive
medication which obviously has to be
spaced evenly throughout the day
and they panic if we're not there at the
times that they expect us
on many occasions the traffic has been
so bad and gridlocked that we've had to
take huge detours to get from one side
of rockford to the other just to try and
get to our clients on time
um my case is simple the more building
of houses will be more cars and more
gridlock this will mean that the sick
elderly and vulnerable residents of our
community will just suffer more and more
i even gave up working weekday mornings
in the area on account of i was just fed
up with sitting in traffic all the time
that's all i've got to say i won't say
thank you just don't check miss reed
anything no
okay thank you very much thurman jones
you again as i said before you may
retake your seat thank you thank you for
your contribution thank you
just bear with me
okay
ms jones can i
i don't think i've been past it yet mr
dolbys
so mr dolby would you like to come to
the
microphone thank you
hmm
okay can you introduce yourself to the
inquiry so i know who you are and then
read your statement for me please yeah
can you hear me okay yeah yeah
okay my name is uh clark dolby
uh and i'd like to speak today thank you
sorry that last bit was very faint
it's just saying that i'm i'm going to
speak now that's okay yeah
are you a private individual is it easy
yes sorry private resident yeah okay
okay go ahead
we have seen an overwhelming objection
from residents
and sharing the same views i would like
to speak on the basis that the proposed
development represents a tipping point
on concerns forming the collective
objection we are not against law or the
notion of more houses in their own right
per se
it is the material considerations
prompting us to express real concerns
having read through proposed arguments
and evidence from blow homes i would
like the appeals inspector to consider
that the development will not provide
the community with significant long-term
benefits that would outweigh any
negative effects
bloor's ability to demonstrate to the
contrary is in the form of computer
generated data and focuses heavily on
technicalities relating to the validity
of the local plan and current guidelines
from the government concerning outdated
policies of growth that are due for
review
since the government's stance is slowly
changing to favor climate control over
pushing development
the proposed benefits are a fairly
narrow attraction
simply houses to buy and a short-term
improvement in economics to the area
as is often the case with new
developments
a large uptake of these new homes do not
come from residents within the area
moreover they attract populations from
busiest cities who take advantage of the
housing prices relative to their
location
this actually increases house prices
notwithstanding an increase in council
tax collections
a predominantly residential area with no
significant local attractions
means that any expendable income tends
to be spent outside of the area of
concern
providing minimal economic benefit in
this regard
law makes selective reference to the
national planning framework and use it
to support their case
however there are many other sections of
the framework that developers are
required to conform to which local
residents feel are not being given
enough weight
section 2 states that achieving
sustainable development is
meeting the needs of the present without
compromising the ability of future
generations to meet their own needs
additionally as the uk is a member of
the un
we have agreed to pursue the 17 global
goals for sustainable development in the
period to 2030
these address social progress economic
well-being and environmental protection
digging deeper into the framework
reveals requirements of the developers
to seek the following as per paragraph
11a of the framework
to align growth and infrastructure
which physically they can't do
improve the environment
mitigate climate change and adapt to its
effects
residents are of the view that these
obligations are not satisfied by the
current proposals and that any
mitigation is of token value
law claim that none of the footnote
seven policies of the framework apply to
the appeal proposal
however the gov dot uk website
which is the environment agency section
shows that the planned area and
surrounding sections carry risk of
surface flooding
natural and man-made drainage is over
capacity
just recently four or five of the local
commuting routes were impassable after
one night of rain
i actually had to turn home turn around
go home
are we really to trust that whilst the
surrounding area floods bloor's site
will not only sit dry but not add
pressure upstream and therefore impact
the surrounding area further
our transport infrastructure problems
are well documented and it's been
accepted for some time that an increase
in traffic activity will adversely
impact residents lives and that
improvements to the highway are
extremely difficult or impossible
the assumption from brawl homes is that
residents will simply change their
lifestyle
this isn't in my speech but i'd just
like to say that this morning i had to
turn around on the ashland road and
travel an extra three or four miles to
get here today
also that would have been creating more
emissions and air pollution
three to four hundred pages of charts of
vague and manipulated data
designed to confuse cannot be considered
a replacement for real life experience
and knowledge of the local roads their
quirks and logistical constraints
if you care to digest the information in
the report carefully you will see that
the results are presented as robust
but it is admitted in the report that
the generated data is unstable when near
in severe conditions and that results
should be interpreted with caution
this language used persuades us to
ignore any undesirable results
deflecting from the fact that the stable
results were already approaching limits
in any case opinions can be formed in
many ways in mathematical models i would
therefore urge you to closely examine
the results and not be swayed by
conclusions suggested to you by bloom
rockford and the surrounding areas
benefited greatly from lockdown and the
decrease in traffic on the roads the
increase in wildlife could clearly be
seen not only in the countryside but in
people's back gardens
the resulting return to normality has
since seen these benefits diminish
and an increase in construction works
and traffic can only push this decline
further
london is currently striving towards
reducing emissions outside of schools
which are causing cases of respiratory
and mental illnesses this has been
recognized and supported by the world
health organization
this has been an expensive exercise for
london and we must take a proactive
stance now
the removal of the large tree outside
the school which serves to absorb some
air pollution
being replaced by some saplings
elsewhere is of course a travis theme
mitigation is largely offered in the
form of money
the framework considers this to be the
last result and proves that bloor
acknowledged presence of significant
adverse impacts
and their impotency in being able to
rectify them the proposed financial
contributions to mitigate any material
concerns is a very short-sighted view
the long-term effects from the
development will surely outweigh any
short-term monetary loss
thank you okay thank you thank you mr
dolby just stay there a moment let me
let me just go back through this um
so just want to be clear here
on your one two three on your fourth
paragraph
you talk about the national planning
policy framework yes
um
and you you highlighted section two
which deals um as you say with
achieving sustainable development
just want to be clear are you saying
that in your view this proposal would
not represent sustainable development
yes well the the consideration is that
i mean we do actually need the homes
that's not up for debate
but the infrastructure can't support it
um
i'm not sure how
we get the new homes
without improving the interest
infrastructure so the sustainability of
the development
um
i'm not sure how they can
you know confirm that okay okay as long
as i'm clear on your i mean obviously
the the appellants will have to give me
their take on the proposal and and i'll
hear from the council and rule six party
as well but i just want to make sure i'm
fully understanding your position and
from from your statement here
um
the other one i just wanted to check
with you is excuse me when you
go a few paragraphs lower down
when you make this reference to
footnote seven policies framework and
you you highlight flooding what what are
you actually saying that i i read what
you're saying here
um
[Music]
four of the five local commuting routes
were impassable after one night of rain
but are you saying because because
you've highlighted this footnote seven
are you saying that law is incorrect in
its evidence to say that footnote seven
policies
don't apply here
well as a resident i've obviously got
first-hand experience of the roads um i
actually live halfway up a hill
at the top of washington
our garden is flooded for a lot of the
year
which you wouldn't expect halfway up a
hill the houses at the bottom
um can sometimes have a foot of water
um the roads around this area
every time it rains
there are big puddles there's big
puddles forming along ashendum road so
if you drive through them and there's
school kids there
it's like they're at a water park
[Music]
whether the surveys have been done
correctly or not and and they propose
that there won't be any problems is is
obviously up for debate but the
environment agency does show that the
the surrounding area
is at between low and high risk in a lot
of places and
you can check this yourself i obviously
haven't included
any pictorial evidence as such i've only
got a five minute speech yep
okay
i think the
well no i didn't
sorry just ahead i'm sure um other
residents would remember the date um
that these
routes were impassable as well i'm i
hope someone can help me in finding out
that date maybe we have some photos from
social media to show you i've certainly
seen some photos so so yes i mean that's
that's not a problem i just wanted to be
clear when when you you've referred
specifically to uh a footnote in the in
in the national planning policy
framework i just wanted to hear your
response in that context but you you the
footage is relating to a paragraph 11
in the framework sorry say that one
again it's directly on the page that
references section 11 paragraph 11 sorry
yep okay yeah yeah
no i'm happy with i i i follow what
you're saying there i don't think
there's anything more mr dolby on what
you've said that i needed to ask you
about so again thank you for your
contribution very much invite you to
retake your seat thank you
and i think we've just about
got to a time where i think it's
appropriate for me to break for lunch
now
we'll
i'll take an hour for lunch when we come
back
i'll hear first of all from
helen wright
i'll hear from the others in the order
that i'd indicated earlier
can i please just remind you if you
haven't yet submitted your statement to
the council for copying please do it
over the luncheon adjournment then it
can be circulated
so thank you on that note now i'll
adjourn and we'll resume at
two o'clock thank you
okay
guys
yes
okay
um
um
can i ask you to start taking your seats
please ladies and gentlemen
thank you
the inquiry is now resumed
um
just
so people are aware mr foster's just
handed me uh a slightly updated version
of his
evidence um when he comes to present it
i'll ask him to identify differences
between this and the
originally submitted document
just let me
make a note of the
document
we okay with the live streaming that's
going ahead is it yeah i get the thumbs
up thank you
so we'll carry on moving through hearing
from those interested persons who've
indicated they want to speak and i said
we'd have helen wright would you like to
come to the
witness table please
can i check how would you
prefer me to refer to you miss mrs
well he's fine no i'd i'd rather go with
the miss mrs if that's acceptable to you
ms
that's right
thank you now
is this the same as the document that
you submitted earlier i mean i've just
been handed a copy of it now but i had
got printed that's fine
i'll
double check the
earlier ones bear with me
okay
okay thank you
so much right then would you like to
just briefly introduce yourself to the
inquiry and then read your statement
please okay my name is helen wright i'm
the mother of a 33 year old
son i've lived in washington uh since i
was
in my early 30s for 34 years
i've run a business from my home
i've been a local teacher in the area
and
used the ashland road extensively
throughout that time
okay
i just had one sentence that i'd like to
address to the
um barrister for the appellant which is
not on my side it's just a quick
uh sentence that's all
i'd just like to say to you that um
prepare comparing seo r8
saying that it's uh the most suitable
allocated site
is a bit like saying that the last deck
chair that was on the titanic
before it sank
was the safest
okay so here we go
so my my submission is on behalf of my
page the action and road suffers
sorry sorry i i didn't quite catch that
your submission is on behalf of my page
on facebook the ashington road suffers
34 years ago before i moved to rochford
an acquaintance warned i have one piece
of advice about going to live there
don't
his reason the nightmare that was and is
ashen and road does anyone seriously
doubt that all these years later the
situation has not deteriorated further
fast forward then to 1996
when as a rochford-based working mother
myself i had to leave a home by 8 10 a.m
in the morning to have the best chance
of avoiding the congestion now it is 7
10.
is this even possible or practical for
today's working parents
because since 96 the population of the
district has increased by around 10 000
to an estimated 86 000 so looking at the
figures from the census i calculate that
those two young to own a car number
approximately 16 thousand leaving the
remainder
remaining seventy thousand or so as
potential car owners and when you travel
the ushen road during the rush hour you
feel pretty much as if every one of them
is in front of you
yet apparently the proposals for seo
r8 has already been said
um
have various mitigations
one of them is to remove the bus lay by
outside holt farm pretty much opposite
the entrance and exit to the planned
development forcing buses to stop in the
road
if a home delivery van can bring us in a
road to a standstill imagine what a bus
or two blocking the highway every 15
minutes or so will do
since i started the action and road
suffers page i have collected a
selection of photographs videos and
screenshots and conducted qualitative
and quantitative research to try to
capture the situation in a more concrete
way and examples of my data have been
shared with you
i did this because it is asserted that
people will change their habits you've
already heard all that
so my examples along with my primary
survey of 1200 road users
and i believe that's an extremely high
number for a qualitative survey
should illustrate our present daily
reality and my main points are as
follows this picks up on something that
mr francois said when you asked him how
many of those cars from the new
development would be coming onto the
ashland road at russia
58
of the traffic on this road travels in
the rush hour five and three quarter
hour period
therefore the remaining 42 percent
travel in the remaining 18 and a quarter
hours
it should come as no surprise then that
russia is a time of major congestion and
delay
over 90 percent of russia's travelers
advise that they could not change their
time of travel
61 of russia respondents have already
changed their route of travel and a
further 29
cannot do this
out of the remaining 10
a mere 1.9
could do so in the future
over 95 percent of those who've changed
their routes responded that this is
inconvenient or more costly for them
and overall
87 of respondents who are able to change
their time of travel to a more
convenient time have already done so or
are not helped to
ergo
if people can change their ascendant and
root route or time of travel they're
also already doing it
we cannot expect further change
so lastly to the main pinch points from
the survey all the respondents were
asked to choose their two main horrors
this was actually equally shared between
three spots but i'm going to focus on
two firstly the hall road junction which
has been referred to several times a
daily calamity for many this is where
the traffic always comes to a stop
incidentally the traffic survey carried
out prior to the whole road developments
another 600 nod houses some years ago
forecast that this roundabout which
impacts us in a road massively
will be
126 percent of capacity in the morning
russia and 112 of capacity
in the afternoon rush hour and you can
forget about 2029 because that is this
year
secondly just getting onto the ashland
road in the first place
i will provide some context from my
qualitative research
people site the side roads are oxford
road hot farm way or just getting out of
their driveway in the first place as
their main problem the mitigation
proposals will help help neither of the
two choke points that i have outlined
even journeys outside rush hour are a
frequent catastrophe
journeys impacted 40 percent or more of
the time are three times more than those
under 40 percent
the highest percentage of journeys
impact is 40
or more
and that's between 41 and 50
and with 70 and 80 percent holdups being
very close behind
and it's also worth noting that this
survey was carried out at the height of
the covid pandemic when work patterns
were very much more home-based
it's obvious of course that the increase
in the population district has
contributed to the severe impact on
action and road but how can this be
possible when the birth rate is falling
as part of my research i spoke to an
owner on the braised lane estate
another feeder to washington road he
explained that although most of the
people living in the new development are
local
most of the residents in turn sold their
houses from peak to people from outside
of the area
is it fair that they should be allowed
to continue when the ash in the road is
already beyond capacity and there are no
plans to build any kind of relief road
the most direct route to and from
rochford south end hockley ashington
knuden and fanbridge all of which are
under attack from development is via the
ashen and road and or the hall road
roundabout
bloor homes may look in their crystal
ball and provide you with their wish
list regarding what might happen in the
future but i am telling you what is
happening
now so finally
i give you my definition of severe
a collective cry of anguish from the
users of ash england road that has been
ignored for 34 years and is increasing
okay thank you
ms wright can you
come back to the table please thank you
yeah don't want to outstand me welcome
miss reed any
questions thank you okay
can i check then you you've obviously
included a lot of figures in here what
what i've seen from you in terms of your
written representations
was uh let me turn it up
so
i'm not quite sure it's not dated so it
wasn't um
i can't tell you when you sent it but it
was received by the planning inspector
on the 25th of november
2021
and there's uh a number of pages
photographs
can i be clear um the figures in your
the statement that you've just given now
if i want to try and verify any of those
do i turn to this written submission
that you've put in if you want to verify
the figures
uh they are you will be able to take
them from the questions on the survey
so
so so is the answer yes i i look at this
document that you submitted on the 25th
of february of november or at least
that's that's when the inspector
received it that's right so okay so i
haven't tried to correlate but that's
right the nine questions that constitute
the survey okay um
are where i have drawn
those
figures from yeah okay i've got nine
questions there and obviously i can see
the answers to those although i've not
gone through them in detail but you're
telling me that what you're what you've
just summarized now that's where it all
comes from
okay
i think that's possibly all i needed to
clarify with you there
i do have one point of clarification if
i may it's just okay
bear with me then let me just try
yeah i just i it was just me wanting to
check where the figures came from and i
think that you've you've clarified that
thank you now
uh
that's right so
i i don't
have anything further so
misread
so it's just it's just a point of
clarification if i may um it was just in
respect to the survey because i'm just
looking at the covering letter that you
sent in
and you set out that you represent the
ashington road sufferers and what the
nature of that group is
and in recent months you conducted a
survey collected testimonials and
requested photographs from our members a
selection of which i enclosed with this
letter
and it was just who you surveyed was it
the members of your group oh no
their survey
was on surveymonkey i paid for it myself
and we shared it on the rochas
supporters site i shared it on my
facebook page
it was
shared on caring about rochford
i
shared it in uh we love surf end
and i asked everyone repeatedly
to share on their own page
i had quite a few
pm's and
messages via the various channels
asking me if i could provide them with
the link
okay it's
it's a bit of a mess
survey monkey with sharing but we didn't
manage to work out how you do it don't
ask me to it's
no no no don't worry i'm not eight
months ago my mom died but but i didn't
manage to provide a link and with you
know we gave everyone a chance
um i know 1200 people is a lot of people
but there are 87 000 people who live in
the district so
you know and we kept it going for quite
a long time
okay
thank you very much then miss right you
may
resume your seat thank you
so let me
move on
as i said before i hadn't had any other
requests for being bumped up the order
as it were
so let me just go back to
find where i've put it
my original
list here we go so
next one down on the list was barbara
beer
would you like to
come forwards please and again the same
once you're seated i'll ask you the same
question as to how you'd like me to
refer to you thank you
address you rather
good afternoon everybody
yes so is it
miss mrs muzz mrs beer misses right bear
with me then please mrs beer
right so
same format then please just a brief
introduction so i know who you are and
then read your statement for me please
um
my name's barbara beer
i'm a resident of rochford
i'm a mobile dog groomer by trade
and i travel up and down ashington road
for work and i'd just like to it's not
in my statement but i'd just like to
concur with what um
helen wright just said that i've had to
um
arrange my appointments outside of um
rush hour times in order for my busy
business to function
and if
um a lot of other people were to start
doing that then um
it would cause a lot of problems for me
okay and i'm afraid what you're about to
hear is gonna sound a bit lightweight
compared to everything else you've heard
so far but this is just one person's
experience which i hope will
add weight to our
cause
okay
so bloor and essex highways have
suggested that congestion on the
ashingdon road will be mitigated by
people electing to travel by alternative
methods such as bike and public
transport
this is purely an assumption and has no
basis in fact and i wish it were true
i'm a keen cyclist i'm not the
competitive type but someone who gets a
warm fuzzy feeling from cycling for
local journeys
and i've done so throughout my life
in fact my earliest memory um
of learning to ride is on stabilizers up
and down oxford road
with my grandad watching over the garden
gate
i like cycling to the shops i know it's
doing me good doing the local economy
good and of course it's doing the planet
good
cyclists are known to shop more locally
and make pit stops at local cafes
cyclists call zero emissions and it's
fantastic exercise so taking this option
at every opportunity makes great sense
to me
but not on ashington road
the last time i rode my bike along the
ashington road five cars overtook me on
the uphill section of warner's bridge
five cars with no way of knowing what
was coming over the brow in the opposite
direction
and leaving me nowhere to go if they had
to take evasive action it was dangerous
and it was frightening
and it was the last time
it was the last time i would choose to
ride on that road but not the first time
i felt intimidated there by motorists
and very vulnerable
overtaking cars have often passed close
enough for me to touch them and they
clearly expect cyclists to ride in the
gutter
the road is peppered with potholes and
poorly maintained drains which standard
bikes are not built to cope with one
wobble or swerve could result in serious
injury
so now when i need to visit the railway
station in rochford or the banking hub
the chemist or the council offices i
will use my car
now i know these problems are endemic on
britain's roads and there is currently a
government initiative headed by chris
boardman to deal with them but please
don't allow this to allow you into the
assumption the problem on ashington road
will therefore be dealt with
i don't have any statistics or
any computer models to back up what i'm
saying
i just have 50 odd years of cycling
experience
so i don't need them i do know one of
one young lady who ended up in intensive
care after she hit one of the potholes
and fell off
she was then run over by a following
motorist who was unable to stop or take
evasive action in time
the drivers along there are much more
inclined to take unnecessary risks
overtaking and generally hassle the
cyclists because of congested road
conditions
there is a cycle path that runs along
parts
it starts and finishes randomly and some
of it is destined to disappear if the
blur development goes ahead
the speed limit is 15 miles an hour to
make allowance for pedestrians who may
wander into the cyclist's space
i would say it appears to be designed by
a non-cyclist to accommodate children
cycling to school and back it's
certainly not fit for purpose as an
alternative commuter option
commuters would need a super highway
along the lines of those created in
london which are exclusive to cyclists
and allow them to ride safely at a
sensible pace
but if ashington road could be widened
to accommodate this
then it could be a widened to
accommodate more cars and we all know
that that isn't possible
so i'm afraid there is no incentive for
folk to switch from cars to bikes along
this road and the idea that they might
is simply wishful thinking has already
been said
i just want to finish by saying there
are many other aspects of this
development that i object to
the erosion of our green spaces and our
greenbelt
the consequent impact on our wildlife
and in particular the disappearance of a
number of badger sets from the site
since planning permission was applied
for
the potential mismanagement of our water
table and consequent flood risk
the repurposing of our agricultural land
just at a time when climate change and
brexit appear about to show
globalization as a failed experiment
and that we will once again be required
to source food and commodities locally
but these are not the reasons why
rochefort district council refused
planning permission
they are not political mavericks and we
are not nimbys
they did so because they know channeling
more traffic through ashington road
would quite simply be like trying to
post an elephant through a letterbox
that's all i have to say okay
thank you this is beer um
miss reed any questions
just stay there a moment
i'll check on my
earlier copy of your
statement if i'd highlighted anything i
wanted to ask you
no that was slightly short wasn't it
that you'd yeah previously because there
were time constraints to get it to you
yeah i just did the synopsis
not a problem i just wanted to see if it
i don't think there's anything in there
that i oh there is actually on the
second page i just want to be clear when
you told me near the top of the page you
said the speed limit is 15 miles an hour
what's that on that's the general speed
limit on um cycle paths on the cycle
paths yeah so that's what i thought you
were saying but i just wasn't totally
thank you that's the nationwide thing
which is why a lot of cyclists choose to
cycle in the
in the road in the road
thank you then mrs beer you may take
your retake your seat thank you
and let me just work down my list then
please
um
i think i've got denise crosby next
i pick pun
oh yes you i put a cross i as well as a
tick i put a cross by your name and then
forgot my own shorthand but yes
thank you
so um
the the taylorsons doctor and doctor and
mrs cj and jm taylorson one i understand
that both of you want to speak and can i
have one of you up with your
your statement then please
sorry which
which statement
do i need
yes certainly
so thank you
so i've got i've just got
jay here so what what what name should i
note oh sorry mrs j m taylorson mrs j m
taylorson mrs jm taylor
and then
okay thank you bear with me while i put
these numbers on it
okay thank you so again if you wouldn't
mind just briefly introducing yourself
so i know who you are working as a
private resident of watchful speaking
private residence
just to add to um something the last
speaker said actually about cycling to
school as a commuter option
um
i'm slightly perfect as to which
decade law homes are in if they think
that a busy mother with three children
who's probably got to drop them off at
different schools and then go on to her
own job after work after doing that can
actually
cycle to school
and i don't actually think using the
buses would be
much better for those of you that know
the bus network here
anyway um i'm slightly
aiming my talk at um
slightly differently because
i appreciated that you didn't want to
hear the same things over and over again
nonetheless i think it's a serious
concern has actually just been touched
upon by the last couple of speakers
so i agree wholeheartedly with the
objection and points made by others
about the extra houses burning fossil
fuels pollution
the traffic and the pollution that will
cause also i think a detrimental effect
on rochefort businesses to be honest
with you
um
already choosing at rockford uh
sometimes you're weighing up rochford
hockley and you think traffic no i'll go
to hockley because uh and i do think
rockford is gonna disappear or suffer
severely if this goes ahead with the
weight of traffic because it's just not
gonna be a viable option to go to
rochefort to go to the
to the bank or the banking hub or
whatever when you can go in the other
direction in half the time
as well as the ecological objections
that people are raising mr dolby
mentioned about
selling trees and bushes
but in addition to that
all of those things
i actually have grave concerns about yet
more of our land more of our farmland in
this area disappearing under concrete
there's been quite a lot already should
we say
as a nation and again the last speaker
touched on this as a nation we are far
too dependent on imported food and the
problems and dangers of such dependency
were recognized as long ago as world war
ii
now this actually goes on far far beyond
that to almost a century of us being
dependent on the rest of the world for
it to import food from well we had an
empire there were lots of places that we
could import cheap food from but those
are gone it's not the case anymore that
gave rise to the dig for victory
campaign where men and women were
encouraged in the world war to grow
their own food
now
those problems still exist and that was
shown most recently in the pandemic
whenever there's a crisis the first
thing people all do is rush out to get
food
now in the pandemic the first things to
run out
well apart from toilet rolls
was fresh produce
we can and should be growing more of our
own food and supporting our farmers to
feed the nation
in the short term it's you know an
option sell the land you'll make more
money selling it for housing you will
farming it but that that could and
should change and i don't have the
relevant document numbers to hand but i
do believe there is government policy to
regenerate the countryside and to rewild
someone else's talk today about the
effect on wildlife and nature
and farmers can play a key part actually
in that by the very nature of what they
do
um so you know
there's plenty of place in the world
where they can't grow food they're too
hot they're too cold they're too dry
they're too wet they have too much wind
we actually have a temperate climate and
a green first whole land it should be
prized and valued as such not turned
into housing estates we don't have a
vast empire anymore that we can import
the cheap food from we've left the eu
there's never actually been a better
time for the government to invest in and
regenerate our farmland and our farming
industry rather than let it disappear
under concrete forever
and finally
both the government and rochefort
district council have declared a climate
emergency
i've declared it but we haven't yet seen
a great deal of action the scientists
have told us we now have a little over
only 10 years
to reverse the situation or it's lost
now things like trees bushes or green
plants they all absorb carbon dioxide
pump out oxygen they're like the lungs
of the towns and the cities now you
can't with due respect to bloor homes
plant a few saplings to replace mature
trees and ecosystems
just doesn't balance the equation
if we look after nature nature will look
after us it's as simple as that the
proposed development will be detrimental
and damaging to the local area
to the existing residents and the local
environment
it's actually all about money and i
would like to close with a native
american proverb
only when the last tree has died and the
last river has been poisoned
and the last fish has been caught
we realize we cannot eat money
that's all i got to say thank you this
miss reed any any questions
no i i have no questions on that either
mrs taylor so thank you you may
retake your seat and
[Music]
taylor and partner please come to there
[Music]
thank you
wow
so what what um what name have i got
here then please is is this
my name's dr chris taylorson dr chris
taylorson just bear with me then please
and i agree with everything that my wife
said
okay bear with me
right well again a brief introduction
and then
read your statement my name is dr chris
taylorson i am a resident of ashington
um and use the washington road very very
frequently
my objections
actually fall into a number of
categories but do mirror most of what's
been said before so i'll try and keep it
short
um
and i am in agreement with what my wife
said i'm not always in agreement with
her but i am in agreement with her on
this loss of green space in rochford
would be a disaster ecologically we
could put the land to better use i'm
sure of that it could be farmed or it
could be used for providing health and
wellbeing benefits for local residents
and for the people of rochford
we do live in a nature depleted enviro
country one of the worst in europe in
fact for that
and if we are intent on tackling climate
change then we shouldn't be
building on green on green land
the 662 extra households located next to
and feeding into the existing busy road
stroke area stroke the infrastructure
that goes with it
i feel would be an absolute disaster and
place an intolerable burden on local
infrastructure and services
the point my wife made about rochford
being could easily die because of this
i know for a fact that i very rarely
travel to rochefort now down the
ashington road and prefer to go to other
places even though i do like rochford as
a shopping center
because it's so difficult to get there
down the ashington road
anyone who's driven along washington
road and i know there's lots of figures
showing traffic load down the road and
it being acceptable and all this sort of
thing but it's not what we
as local residents
what we experience as local residents
is especially during rush hours but not
just during rush hour during
all day thursday when the bins are being
collected
when
on the way back here i've been home at
lunchtime on the way back here one
tesco's delivery van
causes mayhem on the ashendum road
passing the school
the lay by which is where a lot of
people park to drop kids off and pick
kids up
at
quarter to two is already full of cars
there's no space for people to stop
there and pick pick up
i believe that the the figures quoted in
the studies the traffic density and
pollution figures i don't recognize
those figures at all they're not what i
experienced and i'm sure they're not
what everyone who who who's against this
development experiences
and i think far from boosting local life
and local businesses it's going to
damage it
immensely
people already bulk at traveling down
the ashington road and i think it's only
going to get worse if we have
662 houses with associated cars and that
may be as as mark francois said as many
as 1500 cars
by the end of this development
using washington road on a regular basis
is an absolute nightmare
um there's going to be obvious
detriments of a local community i think
you know most people agree with most
local residents overwhelmingly agree
with this at the 662 houses are going to
produce a situation that's going to be
intolerable
an increase in roadside pollution
and and in particular matters
especially around the local schools
is something that we really shouldn't be
allowing to happen
and widening the road at the point where
it's proposed to be widened
um removing the landmark tree and the
bushes
um
i think will create as mark franswer
tried to point out a dangerous situation
when it comes to
the families and children at the school
gates
local people who live in this area are
totally against this development you
only had to drive down the ashington
road before
the previous meetings to see all the
signs outside the houses all the way
down the road not just around the school
beyond golden cross right down to
washington hill
people are against the development
this tells you something about the
strength of feeling
regarding this development
and i think it's not a suitable proposal
for this area thank you
okay thank you very much dr
taylorson same question miss reed any
questions
no okay
um
i i have nothing extra to ask you dr
taylorson so
thank you for your contribution
right
i've got
i've got john fuller
next southeast essex friends of the
earth now
you'd given me your
statement earlier or at least it found
its way to me just bear with me
can i check if the other party's got
copies of mr fullers
i don't think we do have that one sir
right
do you have another one to handle
right
so in a moment mr fuller i'm going to
ask you
to do exactly the same as the others to
give me a brief introduction and then
read your statement but before you do
i did have the excuse me opportunity to
have a quick look through this
beforehand and i see unfortunately it's
littered with um hyperlinks
one of the things that was made quite
clear when i had the case management
conference
and i totally accept that you you
weren't present at that but the summary
note that i produced from that has been
put on the council's website so is
available but hyperlinks web addresses
aren't acceptable in proofs of evidence
simply because they can be removed or
the content can change so i need to know
if you're referring me to a link that
i'm actually going to see what it is
that you're referring to
so when you've put a lot of these
references in here what you should have
done was extracted the appropriate part
from that web page as a hard copy and
appended it to your statement now
obviously you can't do that here and now
but i i'd be content to accept that
because clearly you've given me these
links
um but i i i can't just work with links
as they stand as i said a moment ago i i
don't know whether what i look on that
if i was to go to one of those whether
it would be the same as what it was when
you had referred to it
so that's what you should have done and
what i'll allow you to do
post your appearance now if you want to
put in extracts of those particular web
links
okay i'll work with what i've got um
i
have been away on a family emergency for
a week and came back late last night to
see the message requesting a statement
be um
handed in to you so that i uh
sat at home last night and typed up the
notes and sent the email to you
and
uh given in the circumstances we just
have to work with what we've got uh i
wasn't at a case conference i doubt
whether other members of the public were
there either no that we will work there
were very few there but but what i did
at the case management conference was
make it quite clear that the matters
that were agreed at that um as i said i
was included in a summary note and i
asked the council to to make that
available on its website so as i say i
wasn't no i wasn't there i'm a member of
the public and i will work with what
we've got
so my name is john fuller i
have been with southeast essex friends
of the earth for several decades i've
lived in rochard district and south end
for over 55 years
the notes that you will see here do have
hyperlinks to
such dubious websites as the the
government website um
on which this much of this material is
actually based um so it was really done
for the benefit of other people to check
and make sure that if i if i give a
statistic that you can look
at where that source came from but it's
not essential so we can work with what
we've got um it's based on the adapt or
dye message adapt or die is very brutal
it's very frank and it's something that
everybody in government and business
needs to pay attention to it comes from
it appears on the government's website
and it is from the environment agency
that we either now adapt to what's
coming to us
or we die it won't be the planning
inspector or me who dies it will be our
grandchildren and we have to face up to
those facts
so
throughout the south of the uk there's
huge pressure for new housing uh house
building to accommodate our growing
population but so much of the housing is
being built in places that are only
accessible by private car they're being
built in on areas of precious wildlife
habitat and often in areas that are
prone to flooding and or close to the
current highest high tide mark this
pattern of development assures us that
more people will be injured or killed by
toxic emissions from vehicles that the
estimated quarter of uk mammals that are
under threat of extinction will indeed
be annihilated and
that abrupt sea level rise caused by
climate change will inundate hundreds of
thousands of homes over the coming
decades
it is incomprehensible that despite
repeated warnings from bodies like
environment agency much of government
continues to support new housing
developments in areas that are
guaranteed to fail our essential short
and long-term needs
to counter this threat this group
produced a video on how to provide the
homes we need within existing brownfield
sites this was sent to every councillor
in southeast essex including all rocha
district councillors you'll see that the
strategy outlined here in that video is
designed to provide new homes in ways
that reduce car use help us to meet the
uk's net zero climate chart target and
meet statutory air quality targets
it's based on the idea of high density
uh homes on existing brownfield sites
that we have already in southeast essex
i must mention uh say a few words about
toxic air and its consequences estimates
vary on the number of people killed
every year by toxic air but it's in it
is in the tens of thousands and i
provide a link to a report from the
royal closure physicians that puts the
figure at 40 000 deaths in the uk a year
and there's another report that i refer
to that says that 5.1 of deaths in
england may be attributable to
particulate matter from vehicles
it must be noted that maternal exposure
can result in premature and low birth
weight babies
inhaled tiny carbon particles have even
been found in mother split sensors
children living in highly polluted areas
of london are more likely to have
reduced lung growth in old age a
lifetime of exposure can result in
reduced life expectancy and an increased
risk of stroke and heart attacks the
links to asthma heart disease strokes
and lung cancer are proven but there are
also suggested links to brain and breast
cancers diabetes dementia impaired
memory reduced ability to learn poor
exam performance mental health problems
including bipolar disorder and
schizophrenia depression and teenage
psychotic episodes not only should we
not be increasing car use by allowing
new homes to be built in areas where it
will be incredibly difficult for people
to use public transport we most
certainly should not be chopping down
superb
trees that mop up toxic emissions and
carbon dioxide briefly turning to the
loss of biodiversity and risk of
extinction of uk mammals i would say
that nature is in crisis a quarter of uk
mammals are an imminent risk of
extinction that is within 10 years
and populations of the uk's most
important
wildlife have plummeted by an average of
60
since 1970.
if government is serious about reversing
the declining wildlife and wants to stop
driving species to extinction it is
obvious that we must stop concreting
over precious green space i will add
briefly the government has
a biodiversity target to stop button off
of biodiversity by 2030 we do not
achieve that government target if we
carry on with development such as this
make a few notes briefly about sea level
rise a lot of people have already spoken
about flooding that's taking place in
the district but i will add that the
river road occasionally floods the horse
and groom pub and i've provided a couple
of links to
stories that have appeared in the local
press about the flooding of that pub and
that area
um the pottstown institute institute for
climate impacts research has warned that
much of the greenland ice sheet is now
doomed to melt the uk government has
helped to fund the how much how fast
research into thwaites glacier in the
antarctic often referred to in the media
as the doomsday glacier sadly the latest
readings from thwaites glacier have
confirmed the worst fears of scientists
it is breaking up much of it will be
gone within 10 years this indicates the
worst case scenarios for sea level rise
are more likely to transpire sea level
rise of up to two meters cannot be ruled
out by 2100 with further sea level rise
from 2100 to 2200 and beyond the risk of
flooding in russia is growing and so the
question i put to this public inquiry is
do you expect new homes to be habitable
for around 100 years
or is it reasonable to expect longer
from brand new housing
if it is longer than this application
must be refused it is probably safe to
2100
but the new housing development is not
safe after that
but notes um what others have said
because
um just touching on what other people
have said here in the public inquiry so
far
they've mentioned that the area is prone
to flooding and of course south end road
the main link to central south end will
over the course of the coming 80 years
be cut off and be flooded um on a very
regular basis that's not where you want
to be building houses that are served by
a road like that
now as i say government is sometimes
brutally frank
and and yet remains chaotic and
disorganized there is little evidence to
see of joined up thinking this group can
only appeal to you and to every level of
government to heed the dire warnings
that appears on the dot government
website from the environment
agency and it's specific and it is clear
we must now adapt or die instead of
choosing death that means toxic air
increased co2 emissions from cars the
extinction of wildlife choose mitigation
and adaptation embrace a totally
different sustainable pattern of
development it's doing instead of
destroying psychopaths my understanding
is that the cycle path on ashland road
will be severed um other people have
spoken about that i don't need to answer
that i'm going to i'm going to pause you
there
um i'm not saying anything of what
you're now saying in the statement i've
been given so i just want to be clear
are you as it were ad libbing now or
have i not been given a full copy of
your statement it
destroying psychopaths and that is a
reference to uh the local mp members
i've got a page that ends with adapt or
die
and i i've i've been given uh
three pages altogether oh no the final
page is is a quarter of a page there
yeah i i haven't got that so well i'll
read it to you and i'll read it and and
i'll ask others too yeah i'll read it
and then i'll hand it to you so instead
of destroying the cycle paths a
beautiful tree that this town has taken
to its heart the hopes of the young who
attend the primary schools on the front
line let us choose life and i give you
the quote to the environment agency
the planning application doesn't fit
with any of government's national
policies on climate change toxic care of
the protection of wildlife i appeal to
you to reject the planning application
and appeal by bloor homes
um the inspector just wanted to mention
one thing that you said today i wasn't
aware of yesterday when i typed up these
notes and that is one of your options is
to impose a planning condition i would
say that if you do go down that route
the only point i would make is that law
homes should be required to pay for new
flood defenses to protect south end road
and obviously make a very substantial
contribution to a new sewage network
because we do not want sewage flooding
through everybody's homes as the sea
levels rise because that is now
guaranteed that is what you have to
contend with it's not what we wanted
it's what
you've accidentally allowed to happen
mr fuller i i just so i i'm clear on
that i mean it's it's it's normal
practice i
for
planning
proposals to be accompanied by
suggested planning conditions and they
they
a number of conditions were included
suggested in the committee report when
this went to committee so it's it's
nothing new and you said you only
discovered it when i mentioned it
earlier well
i don't i don't know how to comment on
that it is certainly common practice
that planning proposals
have accompanying planning conditions
and in some cases they have obligations
through legal agreements so
that's that's fine but we're layman and
lay women here we're not professionals
and i uh haven't been in a public
inquiry for 20 odd years and so i'm not
to know and i do the best i can but i
know that obviously
usually ignored
the extra page that you've uh
no i don't want it i wanted to go to
someone from the council please so that
they can photocopy it so that others
here have a full copy of what you've
just said
so
you have to remind me miss reed have i
asked you if you want to put any
questions to
you haven't sir but i don't thank you
you don't
i don't think i do so the fact that
you've you've retaken your seat you're
one step ahead of me
mr fuller so thank you
now i've got um leanne dolby
so he's
well coordinated now is do you walk
there i get a
statement here so it's going according
to plan thank you
just bear with me while i
do the numbering of the documents again
so you know the routine by now please
just briefly introduce yourself and then
read your statement yeah no worries um
it's leanne dolby it's a misses
um
i live in ashington i'm a mom i'm a
grandmother and i've got a very young
nephew as well and today
i would like to use my voice on behalf
of the children of rochford all of those
children who can't actually come here
and speak for themselves
in 2021 i attended two vigils by the oak
tree outside hulk farm school
this involved standing for two hours on
ashington road pathway whilst the cars
crept by and the congestion worsened due
to rush hour traffic
after returning home i felt sick and i
had a headache so i concluded that it
was probably from the traffic fumes
i recall whilst standing there thinking
how thick the air felt i could see the
pollution pumping from the exhaust pipes
i could smell it i could even taste it
in my mouth
this happened to me on both occasions
and i doubt that's a coincidence
in my opinion the air in our area
already seems pretty toxic so i'm
absolutely shocked that we are even here
today talking about another proposed
housing
development this particular development
will include the possibility of an
additional one to two thousand cars on
our already gridlocked roads
and the removal of an extremely old oak
tree plus other trees and greenery that
are currently absorbing some of the
pollution and reducing particulate
matter in the area
as it stands we have four schools and a
nursery with over 900 younger children
in attendance directly along the section
of ashington road where the development
will impact the most
there are lots of older children and
young adults who attend king edmond
school who also walk along or use the
bus stops along the same section of road
there are many babies and toddlers in
prams or push chairs usually at similar
height to the car exhausts who are
traveling along this road and waiting
outside the schools during the most
congested times of the day
this could mean that there are over a
thousand children already at risk of
possible health issues just in this
small section of rochford
the risks i'm referring to are the
health implications that can be a result
of breathing highly polluted air on a
daily basis
for example worsening of asthma
increased chance of asthma attack
reduced lung growth memory loss and
concentration issues reduced life
expectancy and increased risk of stroke
or heart attack in later life
our children rely on us adults to
protect them and keep them safe from
harm yet i've gone through many of the
documents relating to the development
and excuse me if i have missed a section
but i could barely find any reference
relating to our children's health and
well-being
i was hoping to see detailed analysis on
the current health status of the
children in the area with specific focus
on lung and respiratory conditions
plus modeling or statistics relating to
any fluctuations where we have already
seen the congestion level increase
in the eight and a half years that i
have lived here i have seen the
congestion worsen to to the severe level
it is today so i assume air pollution
will also have increased
i have seen numerous studies that
suggest that maintaining lower air
pollution levels can boost a child's
working memory and improve their ability
to learn
however i could not find any local
assessments within the documentation
which i would have thought
to be quite important considering the
development is likely to increase
congestion and air pollution in close
proximity to so many schools
i assume that if the oak tree and other
greenery are removed then we would see
an increase in particulate matter in
that area
i couldn't find the calculations on this
nor any reference within the modeling
considering this along with the
reduction to the pathway outside the
hulk farm schools which would find the
children closer to the road i am
assuming that the air quality would
worsen in this area therefore putting
them at an increased risk
every child has the right to breathe
clean air and to live a long and healthy
life yet in 2020 an inquest in lewisham
concluded that air pollution had been a
significant contributory factor to the
death of a nine-year-old child in 2013.
this is an absolute tragedy that should
never have happened and should never
happen again
we all have a duty to ensure that
something so devastating never happens
to a child here in rochford
whilst it might be too late for us
our bodies may already be damaged due to
the poor air quality in the area it
doesn't mean that we shouldn't do all we
can to protect the younger members of
our community
if the inspector agrees that the parties
involved haven't done everything
possible to risk assess the impact
on our children to ensure there won't be
any negative effects on their health
then i would kindly invite him to act
now before we lose a child and to
dismiss this
okay thank you very much mrs dolby
um miss reed
i have no questions either thank you
miss dolby
uh
has mcvanner arrived mr vanna right
oh that's the last sheet for that one
yeah thank you
bear with me a moment
um
um
okay welcome mr vanner and uh
again introduce yourself and please read
your statement
good afternoon every everyone my name is
mick manner i'm a retired fire officer
of the essex fire and rescue service of
some 30 years service 20
of those years i was serving at south
end retiring in
1997. now for a bit of history
back in
1966 when i joined the retained fire
service at rochford this is a service
provided by men who live or work
near to a station and turn out two
incidents when called by a bleeper
the stipulation in 1966
was that you had to live within three
minutes of the station traveling at no
more than 30 miles an hour
some men were that close that they ran
from places at work or cycled but i used
the car
i lived 10 8 tenths of a mile from that
station
so it was well in that time required
often getting there second when called
some members live much further away up
the ashington road and as i show you sir
this is the the development brace lane
we had three firemen there uh
two in doric and one in
ashing road itself
i live
here in rochford garden way and this is
my route into some set along the road to
the fire station
the brigade now
um are advertising at the station and
social media for applicants to live
within five minutes that's another two
minutes more of precious time
excuse me
i have made three time runs from mine to
the station with me driving at 30 miles
an hour and a passenger with a stopwatch
on thursday at 8 15 in the morning it
took me seven minutes
six seconds
but when i got to the junction of the
hatching road and somerset avenue i was
fourth in line
the first car was holding us up wanting
to turn right
at 12 25 it took me five minutes 37
seconds and i was first at the junction
later on at
1709 it took me six minutes 14 seconds
and i was second at the junction and
both of us were turning left
as you can see my traveling tides have
increased over the years
not all incidents are fires but many are
special services
as road traffic and shut in lifts cats
up trees and not forgetting the children
with their heads cut
stuck in railings
can you imagine being trapped in the car
by your legs or in the fire how you must
feel when am i going to get rescued
the list goes on on what the services
call to
so that the quicker you get to an
incident the better less damage and less
suffering for those concerned
now many of the objectives to the bloor
estate are concentrating going out of
rockford
but what about the traffic delays coming
back into rochford i am concerned about
emergency vehicles proceeding along
national road at school times there's a
problem
tipping out from a fire station
sorry from the fire station they come
across firstly getting out onto the road
around about a roundabout a crossing
around about a crossing roundabout again
and then finding a close in
holt farm school
then we have if approved another
roundabout for cars to turn into the
blue estate
many times i've been stuck between
the last two crossings where drivers
have nowhere to go to allow the
appliance to go through
i can assure you it's very frustrating
when you are the driver of a fire engine
especially if it's a person or person's
reported meaning
that when the 99 is talking taken
by the control is stated by the caller
that there is a person or persons
reported in immediate danger
so should south end appliances need to
back rochford crew or should they go on
another show in rochford at the same
time they will also have difficulty in
getting through especially from the
ambulance and further up the action road
it was reported to me recently that
there was an incident along the
ashingham road
that's passed
the halt farm school
and the traffic was backed up as far as
hall road roundabout causing the
appliance some difficulty in getting
through
i can assure you that since my time
within the fire service
as a resident of
rochford traffic
has got extremely bad and it's not going
to get better and even more so
if the proposal gets the green light so
mr chairman
please reject this
reject this development
as for the safety of the population of
rochville thank you
okay thank you mr vanner miss reed any
questions
can i can i just check then uh mr vanner
a third of the way down your second page
you said then we will have if approved
another roundabout for cars etc turning
into the blue estate yes am i uh is
there going to be about where the the
oak tree is going to be is at the moment
if i'm looking at the correct plan here
then there's a priority junction
proposed with the right turn lane
so no
no roundabout so that's really what i
want to
i stand corrected sir okay yeah i just
wanted to make sure that
that's what you thought and
and the that i'd looked at the right
plans
so thank you um mr van i i haven't got
any other questions on your
your statement so thank you and you may
retake your seat
so i've got
um
sharon taylor eve
thank you
how would you like me to address you
mrs thank you
so let me put the numbers on this
so
[Applause]
um so i'm a married lady recently and
live in the rochford area
most of my career i've worked
locally in south end
and then
more recently nationally across the
country
um i retired four years ago along with
my husband
that's my history
i'm not an expert witness and can only
provide evidence based on my personal
experience and contact i've had with
other local residents
i've lived in the rochford area on and
off for over 40 years
during this time rochford ashington
canudan rayleigh wakering holbridge and
south end
have all suffered from over development
without adequate infrastructure
resources being provided to support
these additional houses cars and people
let alone its existing residents
i will just show you something i've made
a lot of changes on my um my speech when
you asked us not to repeat what other
people have said so
this will could be quite different to
what you have on your
tell me if you're missing bits out and
tell me when you're adding extra bits
and if you're adding extra bits go a bit
slower so i can make a note of what it
is okay
um
as i said the um there's been a lot of
over development without the adequate
infrastructure
the latest casual the largest casualty
is the ashington road which isn't even a
b road but has to service all the
traffic between those towns
there are many reasons why this
development must be refused but with
only five minutes i'll just cover those
closest to my heart
one of the largest ones was the
reduction or is the reduction of the
pedestrian walks walkway outside hulk
farm schools but that was covered very
succinctly by mark by mr francois but i
will add just a couple of things
the pathways are already full at school
times
for example the reduction will mean that
if a buggy is coming one way there would
be insufficient space for another a
double buggy to pass it if coming the
other way the only option would be to
use the cycle lane which would be
dangerous for both pedestrians and
cyclists
i have personally spoken to dozens of
parents and children at the halt farm
schools and they are seriously worried
about this
my next concern is pollution
this has been touched on by a couple of
people um and i am duplicating things a
little bit here but the air quality is
already poor due to slow moving traffic
car
van and l'oreal missions are at the
height where babies and buggers toddlers
and small children are constantly
breathing in this poisonous these
poisonous gases
and it is dangerous to the hundreds and
hundreds of school children who have to
use the area to access the local
the six local schools
with increasing levels of respiratory
disease in children their health really
must be considered
my other concern was the proposed
vehicle access but this has been covered
again quite um quite a lot by other
people
i'm concerned about the destruction of
our 100 year plus old 100 plus year old
oak tree um it did have a tpo on it due
to its age and it is part of our
community
and really must not be failed its
environmental benefits far outweigh any
new trees that the developer may offer
to plant you don't start seeing carbon
retention for at least 10 years after
trees are planted and even then it would
take many years to be as effective as
our existing oak
one of the infrastructure
queries i have is the doctor's surgeries
have insufficient capacity
i've contacted all the local surgeries
for their views on the extra patients
and although they have to say that they
can accept new patients in reality it's
already very difficult to get to see a
doctor when i've needed an appointment
i've had to dial over 200 times to get
through not criticism of the surgery but
of the number of people needing to use
their service
i was also advised that even though a
surgery may wish to close its books to
new patients this has to be agreed by
the relevant clinical commissioning
group and it's almost impossible to
achieve the criteria to do this
dentists also have insufficient capacity
i've been trying to register with a
local dentist for over two years and
they're unable to accept new nhs
patients i'm in a fortunate position
which is a little bit extra here i'm in
a fortunate position that i've stayed
with my dentist that i've been with for
25 years so i don't need to worry about
that
but i would like to have a local dentist
just for ease i tried again last week
and still no luck and they've suggested
i call back in september and the other
dentist accessible on a bus route in
hockley has also confirmed last week
that they can't accept new patients and
suggested to try again in april
flooding is another concern
and i know this has been covered by some
people but my personal experience is
that this area is already prone to
flooding as is all along washington road
my previous home was on the ashington
road near braes lane and several times
over the last few years this road was
completely flooded
this is due to recent to several recent
housing developments in braze lane and
surrounding areas where green spaces our
natural soakaways have been concreted
over bloor will say that they have
built-in mitigation measures to combat
flooding but i'm sure this will not be
adequate for this area
the new enormous local hall road
development has these in place and some
of these houses and hall road itself
have started to flood
i've also been advised that anglian
water had to compensate a property owner
backing onto this proposed site as the
water system couldn't cope
i was going to talk about conservation
as local wildlife but i think that's
been covered by quite a few other people
and finally my my largest concern with
the development is the ashingdon road it
is already massively over subscribed it
can't cope with the current traffic let
alone probably like 1500 plus additional
vehicles there is no solution to this as
the road cannot be widened or junctions
improved
i'm retired as i said so i can plan the
use of the ashinda road outside of
obvious busy times but even this can't
be going this can't guarantee that you
won't get caught in traffic and delayed
and as others have said just a delivery
vans stopped in the road can cause
lengthy tailbacks and i don't even try i
don't even consider traveling anywhere
on thursdays our bin day
in summary development of this land
would add further pressure to our
already overstretched stretched
infrastructure and no amount of bloor's
money
could
mitigate the un unacceptable
unacceptable increase in the use of
roads water and sewage
schools and health services all of which
are struggling to meet the needs of our
current population
houses are needed but this is the wrong
development in the wrong place
please take all these objections into
consideration and refuse this or any
further large developments in our town
thank you
okay thank you
miss reed know i know i keep asking you
the same question i just want to make
sure thank you
um
i don't
think i need to ask you anything more
on your statement either thank you
thank you hey laurie thank you for your
contribution
so
getting to the end of my list so far i
think is i've got two more
i'll then check if there's anyone else
who i didn't take a name of earlier but
uh
next one
kevin stephens
[Music]
thank you
bear with me a moment mr stevens just
checking on here
yeah yours yours was one that you you'd
submitted something in advance i'm not
quite sure yes
a few of the wording
that's okay well you you may have
corrected one of the things that i was
going to ask you about so all right i'll
keep that to one side and see if if you
say the same but just bear with me i'm
just going to do the housekeeping and
making a note of what i've been handed
here
this
okay i'm ready for you now then so just
introduce yourself please and then read
your statement my name is kevin stevens
i'm a resident of 37 years of
ashenton um and just a normal resident
i think that's fine i'm
am going to go unfortunately
what other people have said but i've got
a different perspective
well
when i say no repetition i don't expect
people i understand that not but it
touches on what they say is just i don't
want to hear exactly the same time time
again so
that's i'm going to start off with you
know government and local councils must
start to understand
when completing these large housing
projects
like the 662 house of pro prep
off of washington road we who live in
this area or these areas the
infrastructure has to be in place and
not just promises like beforehand and
never
never seem to seem to materialize like
doctors schooling dentists social care
hospitals public transport etc etc
but i want to focus
unfortunately on
the local roads of course the elephant
in this blurs project is ashington road
which we all know already is a serious
state
now i want to imprint
a different perspective and permanent
picture in everyone's mind and that's
everyone listening to this as well
the proposal of this 662 houses i will
start very very simply
with each house having only one car
take the average length of a car
and the recommended stationary gap
required and you know this can be this
is a figure that is in the highway code
between each car this will give us three
miles of traffic
imagine this picture of that starting
from hulk farm school pass rocha fire
station and berlin past the airport
manas way through cuckoo corner all the
way to priory park
and that's just one car
well now i have personally spent the
weekends walking around new estates
locally
which is
a state near me which is 10 years of 90
houses off of golden cross and 95
percent of those houses have two cars
some even three or four
also i went around the new estate
took several weekends and weekends is
the main point not when everyone's off
at work
um now we have 662 cut um houses
um
with
say two cars of course that gives us six
miles of vehicles
which now takes the amount of cars from
hulk farm school past priory park past
south and football ground right into
south end down queensway to the kurzler
and then you still continue on for
another mile along the seafront and
that's the picture i'm i'm not a figures
person i don't understand all these
computer workings they've done but
it's it's a picture
i have in my mind and it frightens me
really does
is this really what the everyone the
pla the blur and the local council
expect us the residents to accept
to come out onto our ashingdon road plus
opposite hulk farm school and then try
to continue along our congested local
roads i really hope not
with the current severe stages at
ashington road i it cannot take any more
extra traffic just one as many have
spoken and i won't go into it too much
is the blocking point the one we all
know and live in the area is hall road
west street mini roundabout already
congested
long queues of traffic in all directions
but ashington wrote especially imagine
an extra six miles of traffic trying to
get through there at some point in time
it cannot be improved due to the rochard
school and railway line
also please not to tell me that there
are other routes that can be taken there
are not no way as rectory road an option
all through rockford center be an
alternative
i am pleading to you whoever are making
this decision on this development
to say no but also no to any more major
housing proposals of or along our
ashingdon road until there is another
alternative role structure
that can accept the extra traffic or is
the local kelp you know council
authorities
willing to allow continuous building in
this area until ashina road becomes a
car park before a new road or tournament
has to be built
i hope not for the sake of us residents
that live there i want to finish up my
now by just painting that picture do not
forget that picture in your mind of six
miles of cars added to our ashingdon
road
thank you
okay thank you mr stevens i think you
think in in going through your statement
there you you answered the point that
i'd got flagged so i i won't need to ask
you anything uh miss reed
no
okay thank you for your contribution
roger gardner is the last name
on my list so far as i say i will check
again in a moment
thank you
so mr gardner uh
brief introduction and then your
statement good afternoon my name's roger
gardner
i'm acting as a resident of 42 years on
the ascendant road
um i know the ashland road was once a
good road i wasn't there when it was
built because the romans built it
it's the same road
and
just a few more roundabouts on it in a
bit bellatormet that's all
right
right is blur a totally responsible
builder
do they care about the existing
community and its future
how had a proposed to make sure our
human rights are not violated under the
human right to clean air and healthy
environment which will be severely
affected by the new building works being
carried out and after they have a legal
duty to protect people
right waldies will maybe fit in
sustainable energy heating and hot water
systems to these properties like what
she's being proposed now i doubt it if
the heating and hot water system will be
by a condensing gas boiler how many
trees will be planted to offset the co2
generated from these dwellings a typical
tree
fully grown with around 21 kilograms of
co2 per year
a new condensing gas boiler will run
around 85 percent efficiency and will to
produce 215 grams of co2 per kilowatt of
hour per heat that is delivered the
average boiler uses thirteen thousand
five hundred kilowatt hours of gas per
year and will produce two thousand nine
hundred kilograms of co2 annually to
cover these emissions
um and will produce
you will have to cover these emissions
you will need to plant 138 trees per
boiler per year
you intend to build 662 properties that
means you'll have to plant 91
356 trees per year
where do you intend planting them we are
entering a climate change emergency what
a blur's low-carbon commitment how are
you going to monitor and control pm 2.5
and pm10
this is a dangerous pollutant it's been
discussed before and will affect the
lives of both existing residents and
future generations
right i've been looking at the hodgkin's
elf impact assessment that you had
carried out
um when i read this i was thought is
this the same place i lived in for the
last 42 years
um looking all through it the things
that you say the [ __ ] family practice
yes my doctor surgery for 42 years
they're struggling before the outbreak
that is alone with any more
patients oak dentist is another one
they're not taking anyone for over a
year now it's been going on the other
one you mentioned isn't taking any to
they don't know when
you can can provide financial confusion
for a new primary care facility in the
area but can you provide a staff to work
in it
this is a point you know you can build a
lovely building and fill it with fresh
air forever the whole of this report is
based on assumptions
we don't want a health and future based
on assumptions we want actual figures
after all one spilt you won't care about
us or our environment
okay thank you thank you mr gardner just
let me
check miss reed no
i don't think i need to ask you anything
on your statement there either thank you
mr gardner so thank you you
may resume your seat
um
now as i said a moment ago that i think
unless i missed someone who did indicate
earlier i think that has run through all
of those
who had informed the inspectorate or the
council that they wanted to speak
and attended today to do so is there
anyone else present who wanted to speak
and who hasn't yet spoken
no okay thank you and i don't i'm not
aware that there's anyone who'd
indicated they wanted to speak and
couldn't be here today
i think well benjamin crafts
um i i got him noted as attend and
possibly speak but i don't it doesn't
appear that he's here
similarly for jane gay
um penny and mark
hichman that was it i think so unless
any of those are intended to speak and
for whatever reason haven't managed to
attend today
um i don't know if they're
either here um or simply following on
the live stream but if you do still wish
to speak then please
let the council or the inspector's case
officer know and
who can possibly shed you schedule you
in on another day in the inquiry
but as it stands that seems to me to be
the sum total of statements and views
etc
being put forward by interested persons
who want to speak
so what i'll do now we've got to about
half past three which is an ideal time
for a mid-afternoon break if we take a
20-minute break or so now
i would then expect to move on mr
parkinson with your first witness is
that going to be
okay let's do that then so i'll adjourn
now and we'll resume at
15 50. okay thank you
oh
[Music]
uh
uh
all right
uh
right can can you all take your seats
please ladies and gentlemen
so the inquiry is resumed
um
mr parkinson uh i'm just working out how
we're going to proceed now you your
first witness you said was councillor
eves yes so um if council or councillors
is making his way over just while he
does so we had a quick
um
i had a quick chat with miss reid about
timings for this afternoon yes
which is probably why you were you asked
me
that's the very question i want to
explore yes well that's that's that's a
rarity but good that we spotted it um i
mean i think i'm going to be half an
hour 45 minutes with accounts for the
eaves which will take us to
half past 4 25 to 5. i'm conscious that
cancer leaves has
to go as does all the other counselors
in the room at five o'clock
and also
miss reed won't finish her
cross-examination by five and also
they're going to a full council meeting
together i think it just makes sense to
end at the end of councillor reeves
evidence in chief and then
again tomorrow i i thought exactly the
same i i didn't didn't think it was
going to be necessary to leave council
reeves in imperda overnight so although
it means a slightly earlier finish
potentially it seemed to make sense so i
i'm content with that okay okay
right in that case just let me get the
well tell me what documents i'm going to
need i i've got um
a proof and a rebuttal proof i think yep
so you need counselor eve's proof in
rebuttal
mr blair's
proof not the rebuttal his proof and the
appendices
okay just bear with me then
proof and appendices yeah
okay i've got them
within easy reach so
i'll just get to them
the
other two documents are
the original um
transport assessments which is cd 1.14
cd 1.14 yeah
[Music]
and
and then at the
very beginning of the day i mentioned a
new document
that i said
wouldn't be a big issue um and i've now
lost it
here it is um
which
um the other side of scene and we've got
copies as well but just
okay so this one's already been
circulated
yeah i think we're
um this is a google
maps aerial image
of the wider
area yep um and
we'll explain
why in a bit more detail when we get to
it but in short to deal with this point
about other alternative routes okay so
just bear with me so i've got that the
only one i just want to
try and get out now is the ta
cd 1.14 yes cd 1.14 okay
and actually there's only one it's a map
within that that i'm going to and it's
at the only page so i don't know if it
makes sense for everyone to get it up
now so we don't kind of okay well i'll
have it hand when we get there you let
me know which page we need to yeah
okay
yeah i think i think i've got more or
less everything within easy reach there
so
ask you to
introduce your first witness then please
thank you sir um good afternoon cancer
eaves
what i'm going to do is if you can take
up your proof of evidence
i'm just going to formally introduce you
to the inquiry by reference to
paragraphs 1.1 and 1.2 of that
so we can see there that you're
adrian eaves and you're a member of
watchful district council and the board
member for hockley is that right please
and you've been a counsellor since may
2016 and re-elected again in may 2019
and you're a member of a number of
committees including the council's
development committee
yeah that's still correct yep
okay
um and then we can see also that you're
deputy leader of the watchful district
residence group
what i'm going to do is you cover
four main topics in your proof
i'm going to go through them in turn to
do it by topic so the first one
is existing traffic conditions
then
second one is traffic conditions
proposed by the development
and whether or not the impact is severe
the third is
ways of avoiding the problem
and then the fourth topic is safety
concerns at the rectory road roundabout
existing traffic conditions traffic
conditions proposed ways of avoiding the
problem and safety concerns at the retro
road roundabout so if we start off with
existing traffic conditions
so if it's okay i'm not going to ask
miss councillor eves to
to read out large chunks of his proof
just take a paragraph read it out short
one as a jumping off point yep as long
as
you're content that you're um putting
the relevant information before the
witness and the inquiry i'm quite
content with that thank you sir so if
you can start off councillor eves if you
turn to paragraph 4.4 of your proof
okay
um and if you just short paragraph if
you just read that sound
there is clearly an existing level of
congestion on the local highway network
this is a point that has been stressed
by local residents in objection to the
application
further the existing congestion is
identified and acknowledged in the ta
okay i just want to explore that topic
in a bit more detail can you take up mr
blair's proof of evidence
and once you get there can you turn to
paragraph 4.4.8
can i just clarify are we looking at so
it's it's the text of his proof
uh i think you you're in the
dependencies if you go back to the
beginning and then turn to page 14 at
the bottom
is paragraph 4.4.8.
sorry i'm a little bit uh oh sorry lost
on this one i don't know if you can help
me out on this one so it should have a
heading in the middle of the page
morning peak period
from what i can
for what i can see counselor looking
they look so you've got some diagrams on
those pages you don't want diagrams you
want you want a text document
hopefully if you go right back you might
have mr i think he might have the wrong
proof of evidence there it's mr because
i can see the emery logo at the top it's
mr it's mr blair's
proof which has got counsellors it's got
that logo at the top that one i'm just
holding it up so you can see tetra
attack
sorry which one
got that low that logo
that one all right okay thank you
i mean it might be actually
i can just read out the paragraph
because it's not i might say yeah let's
let me just do that so a paragraph this
is uh whilst i'm content with that
i i don't want us to be doing this all
the time so i i want to make sure that
council reeve is is familiar with that
bundle of documents that he has in front
of him obviously there's a difficulty
finding this particular
point
i apologize
would that would that be help the the
opponents have got a clean copy of the
uh the relevant document will be
okay it's it's it's winging its way to
you
thank you
right so um paragraph four point four
point eight so to put this in context
this is
mr blair's account of the the site visit
that he carried out to the site
marigold
4.4.8
is dealing with the
the morning peak period
and i'll clarify with mr blair and to
course what what that
period is
but he says my general observations of
the morning peak they're under the wider
highway
where the wider highway network operated
freely for a short time perhaps 20
minutes or so significant volumes of
pedestrians emerged from their homes and
walked to and from hulk farm schools at
that time the use of pedestrian crossing
did cause cues and slow more moving
traffic down washington road the
situation quickly returned free flowing
after 9 00 am
and i just want to pick up on that
comment about in the morning peak
the wider highway network operated
freely and get your your account on that
that's not my personal experience i must
be honest
i have lived in the area all my life
and regularly use this road
and i do find that it is regularly
especially at peak times backed up quite
considerably
um especially from what would be the
junction
roundabout
called a junction four okay well let's
just i think it would be helpful to
just sort of break this down into time
periods and to look at the plan so that
we're all looking at the same thing
um so
have you got the transport assessment cd
1.14
it's the it's the white file
right
right it's the white file i'm told that
you have
right in front of you apparently this
one oh that one yeah yeah yeah okay
so if you can get that up and what we
need
is it's appendix c
um
it doesn't have a page number but
it's around if you turn to page 86
start there and we'll navigate from
there
page 86 is the end of the the text
and then there's some figures
skip
you skip the page that says figures it's
the next page
it's a page that says facilities plan
are you on that yep okay
so let's
um
deal first with the period between 7 am
and 8 am
and
if we just locate on the
plan we have
the hall road roundabout
so
it's just
just um under where it says watchful
primary nursery school
next to the station right so 7 a.m to 8
a.m
can i have your view on
the level of traffic
and and what you'd see on the ground
between that period 7 00 am and 8 am
before you before you answer
council reeve have i got the right plan
here
facilities plan figure one figure one
yeah okay i just wanted to
before we get too far down the line i
want to make sure i've got the
the right right plan in front of me so
i'm sorry you may need to put that point
to
your witness again it's so he's clear
thank you it's the the best plan i could
find that sort of shows
shows what we need to look at um
okay so it's between the period 7 a.m
and 8 a.m
at the hall road roundabout junction
yep what you would see if you were
driving in that period
i would be coming from alternative two
directions one would be from the
hawkwell which will be stroud green as
you see it on the left there
on those sort of times it would be
typically backed up to the
new roundabout
which is
shown against on on the map there where
hall road is written
there is actually a new roundabout
leading onto the uh recently developed
estate there
um so that would be backing up to their
going to the roundabout there at that
time of day that is not unusual
okay so just so that we've all got it
when you said backing up
a long haul road
to the roundabout can you just
if you come back from the railway bridge
yep
going left along the paper as we see it
yeah and you come to a small roundabout
which goes to james drive
and the likes that is actually the
roundabout that was built as part of the
application for the hall road
development okay
so it would be regularly back to that
sort of area okay and
for for how much of that hour between 7
00 a.m and 8 a.m would the the queues be
be going back back that far
my experience is somewhere around about
the
um
half seven between seven and a half past
and it's always been regularly somewhere
not far off that roundabout at that
time and so i mean i i don't sit on the
road there to find out how long it goes
for but the indication would be
that it is a
a regular problem at that time okay so
that's hall road what about ashington
road southbound what would be the
position there between when i've come
from that direction it is normally
snowed up um well down past the daley's
road um
sort of direction
sorry past which road that's going north
yeah
ashleyden road yeah you said
daley's road
which is the first roundabout you come
to well it's sort of noted as a
roundabout on the on this plane okay
it's just before the centuries catholic
primary school
yep
that's uh noted um to be well along the
problem that you have along the these
two times
is that in actual fact along the whole
of the ashingdon road at those times it
is
very very slow
very slow
okay and then that's the period seven to
eight
um
same question in relation to the period
8 am to 9 a.m
i've got a less experience of that one
there but from what i understand it is
as bad
uh councillor laurene shaw would be able
to
testify to that okay
very was about the same is that how you
would yes okay
it's not my personal experience but that
is what i understand that uh
councilloreenshaw experiences when she
does her
um collection for the food bank okay so
we'll pick that up with councillor shaw
tomorrow so your your experience is
seven to eight and council ashore will
speak to eight to nine
okay
and
you can i have your sort of general view
on whether congestion
on and around washington road has got
better worse or stayed the same over the
last 10 years or so i don't think
there's any doubt that it's got worse
and why'd you say that
well i've experienced it
i work in the area i've had
my businesses have been always based in
the area and for the last 15 years i've
been in ashington
and so
i use the ashington road consistently
and it has become quite obvious
that it has become a bit of a hot spot
to say the least
okay well i think we'll leave that there
because we've heard a lot from local
residents in terms of existing
conditions this morning i want to move
on to the the second heading which is
what will be the effect of granting
permission
and you deal with this in your proof
at paragraphs 4.5 to 4.6
can i put this plan away
uh yes they can go now
i'll put it
within reach just in case
i'm sorry you may need to uh sorry it's
that point again too back to counselor
eve's is proof yep and then
4.5 within that 4.5 okay
and counselors can i just ask you to
read out paragraphs 4.5 to 4.6
4.5 reads table
uh 2.2 to 2.6 in the ta show a number of
junctions operating above practical
capacity in the assessment year
both with and without the proposed
development
and an increase in congestion with the
proposed development
this mirrors the current experiences and
concerns of the local residents
4.6 as i drive regularly along the
ashingdon road rectory roads i can
confirm that i have been regularly
caught in traffic that has resulted in a
doubling of the journey time on many
occasions and at various times of the
day
it is disingenuous of the developers to
conclude that the existing roads have
capacity
to accept the increase in traffic and
dismiss the points at which the
modelling confirms that the roads even
with the junction improvements will
exceed capacity
the impact on the roads in the area will
be severe and irreversible should
development be allowed to proceed
okay now in paragraph 4.5 you're talking
about
what
transport assessment and its addendum
showed
things have moved on slightly because mr
blair has
done some remodeling so i want to take
your views on the appellant's current
position
on
modeling and in particular at the hall
road roundabout
so can you turn to mr blair's
proof
and then within that it's his appendix
14
which
is
there's two volumes of appendices it's
volume two of two
and within that it's page 35.
uh 35
35 being the first page of that appendix
is that what you're yeah yeah yeah mrs
helpfully numbered his appendices which
is
incredibly helpful sorry can i just
confirm uh page 35 page 35 it should say
tech note 3
you're in the proof i think it's in the
folder maybe
you're originally in
if you look at the bottom of those pages
is it does it say volume
to
this one here no no in the folder you're
in what does it it does it say that
volume 2 yeah volume two now within that
you does it say volume two brackets two
of two
okay
that's what you need
and that's volume one you're into if you
go bit further
travel plan statement
um no a
bit further back
and then you eventually get to when it
starts to say two of two in brackets at
the bottom of the page
a bit more bit more
around about where that poster note is
maybe
huh
he doesn't say volume two of two
volume
volume
okay now within that turn to page 35.
okay
okay so what this is
we just look at the heading is
tech note 3 updated junction modeling we
turn over the page
we can see
from paragraph 1.1 that
the aceta so that's the
ta that came with the application
included traffic modeling for the
following five junctions
we can see them listed there
and then if we jump ahead to paragraph
1.9
we can see that mr blair has then
done some adjustments he's validated the
models
but updated the temporary growth rates
and the trip framed
to produce
various models that are listed below
there
don't worry too much about any of that
and what the changes are because i want
to go to the outputs okay
and if we then skip ahead to page 45 at
the bottom
there's a heading junction for
washington road hall road
west street junction yep you got that
right yep
now
because i think it's the first time we
sort of looked at this in the inquiry so
let's i'll just go through
what it shows in terms of the
how how the table works we have up at
the top
for this junction so the whole road
junction the am peak column
and then pm peak column
it has in brackets 745 to 845 for the n
peak
i think that should be 7 15 to 8 15
but don't worry about that we can
clarify that let's just take that as the
am peak
we have the p and peak for the second
column
then we have various scenarios
down the left hand side
so if you see the one that is yours in
color hopefully yeah you can see the
green colored one
baseline
2019 baseline tt validated model
that is the appellant
baseline case for the existing
conditions case
then if you go down to the fourth column
there's one that says
2029 baseline tt validated model tt
tempo
yes
that is the position
i hope it's okay to to lead through this
um that's the position in 2029
without the development so that's what
will happen in 2029 if permissions
refused okay
then at the bottom we have 2029 with
development
okay so that's what will happen in 2029
if mission is granted yes yep
then
along the left-hand
set of rows we have the various
approaches to the junction hall road
ashton road west street
and then for each of the peaks we have
max
rfc
don't worry too much about that but then
we have average delay
and max q can you see that
yeah okay
so
if we take for example
the
ashington road
arm into the roundabout in the 2029
baseline
140.
what is that that's 140 140 brilliant
and then what what does that change to
with the development
uh down to the bottom
uh
with development at 451 451 okay so
permissions granted
451 second delay
per pcu
if it's refused 140. if we do the same
with the queue
it says what does it say for the
2029 without the development
uh sorry we're looking at the washington
road kingdom road uh
so that's
33 yeah and with the development
118 okay
now your view please on doing that
comparison
2029 with and without the development at
this junction your view on
um
applying the paragraph 111 of the mppf
test whether the residual
cumulative impact would be severe what
are your comments on that well i think
that
unfortunately i think the applicant here
has shot themselves in the foot because
it does actually prove
uh in the
figures that they're produced here that
the the impact is severe i mean you're
looking at a
a huge increase
in traffic and backlog
and it's in their own
data
it might be said well
yeah this is just one junction it's just
the whole road junction i mean what
would be the effect of that so 451
seconds that's about seven and a half
minutes
what what and 118 pcu
pcu is
um
without being
taking it very simplistically as a
car basically
what would be the effect of that um
if that was experienced at the estrogen
at the ashton road hormone junction i
think it has the potential to produce
gridlock there because the if you're
looking at that much delay
um
you know you're talking about
it
being the whole length
from
let's say hall road to rectory road
is a standstill while it's waiting to go
through the roundabout at hall road okay
we'll explore that table and and what it
shows um
later in the week with mr blair but
thank you for your your comments on it
which moves us on to our next heading
which is ways of avoiding the problem
if you can go to mr blair's proof
and within its paragraph point two point
sixteen
uh twelve point two point sixteen
yeah the text of the proof
uh is it's the bound copy to your left
oh sorry yeah okay yeah there's that one
so 12 12.2.16
1.2
6.16 on page 5 okay
and it says um
the lpa slash hhs state that the council
does not accept that
increased congestion will lead to
drivers changing their journeys it's
widely accepted that drivers do vary
their time of journey and route to seek
what they consider to be the optimum
balance
and it goes on to talk about
other matters that we'll come back to so
i just want to split that up into the
potential to
change your journey time to get to where
you want to and the potential to change
your route to get to where you want to
and we'll start off with changing your
your route
have you got a copy of
yeah
and i just want you to with reference to
this plan
talk us through the feasibility of
changing your route so i think what
would be helpful is to explain
where people are trying to get to
normally
and how they would get there on or not
without going
through watchful
town centre and down washington road
i think the biggest problem is that if
you're trying to look for alternative
routes from most of the villages that
are around this area here there are no
alternative routes
um what i
the way i've explained it is that it's
almost like ashington road is like the
middle of a um
an egg timer
you've got um if you're going towards
south end
you've got um
hockley ashington south fanbridge uh
knuden
um
all the villages out that way
uh they're they're trying to get all of
them are converging on the ashington
road if you're coming back to
towards um
the hockley direction on the on the
roundabouts if you're coming from the
south end
uh direction
you would then be coming from
uh sutton
wake ring
shuberness
the the near side of south end
um and if you were going from
um
uh the arterial trying to get uh over to
any of the other side of the ashingdon
road you'd be coming down cherry orchard
through hall road
and
splitting from there
there is the problem is that there is no
option
other than to use the ashington road if
you want to get
to either side of the ashington road
there are no
good options
if you actually
uh wanted to
let's say for instance take the
securitis route and go down the 127
which you could do if you went down
cherry orchard
um or if you came from that sort of
direction you would
you would
basically have the same sort of problem
you wouldn't really you certainly
wouldn't be gaining anything timing-wise
that's for sure
the problem is that there is no
there is no alternative
ashington road is the bottleneck
and it is it is the neck
of the egg timer
and i i have failed to see as someone
who's lived in the area all my life
how you can avoid that problem
okay
thank you
um
anything else you want to say on
alternative routes before we move on to
alternative times
and leaving earlier or leaving later
well my experience has been that
because i run a business i come out at
various times of the day
and i do tend to find that there are
issues
now with um traffic at various times of
day people have already cited how things
change when you have a delivery van stop
or when the dust cart is coming around
or when there's a bus
the other thing is as well to bear in
mind that there's been a huge increase
in traffic
um since uh
if you take a baseline before covid it's
been very big um after uh
after that uh and it there it doesn't
seem to be any way
that that can be mitigated against
and
do you have any comments on the on the
practicality of moving your
the time that you you commute no the
biggest problem with that is that
there's a total misunderstanding of the
demographic of the area
um i think that's one thing that has
been completely missed out in the
applicant's
paperwork
the problem is that what you've got in
the in this area
it's very much of a middle class kind of
area so
people are employed
they have
contractual great obligations to be
at
work at certain times
the service industry the teachers
they work in factories etc so to suggest
that
they could move their times of using the
transport network or using the roads
is quite frankly a rather bizarre thing
to suggest
i can't see how that would happen and
the other thing to bear in mind as well
is that there is no option
at the moment on the on the table for
more roads
or widening to
make significant increase in the traffic
uh flow in the area there are no options
and there is nothing as far as i'm aware
being even discussed on that
okay well let's i think that leads us on
to the
one of the other factors that the
appellant points to which is sustainable
travel enhancements now before i ask you
about that i do apologize um there's one
additional document that i'm going to
refer to i always do this
and it's cg
1.1
uh sorry
it's cd
4.09
um
it might be
is it it's going to be in the car is is
this in the context of sustainable it is
yeah okay so it's the note it's the
consultation response from essex county
council october 2020
right well i think i i think i can see
the fold it ought to be in
so
4.9 i've got a letter dated the first of
october
uh
children
um if it helps is it also in councillor
shaw's evidence at appendix 2 if that's
a bit easier um it's the highways bit of
it first of october
um
i i don't think council shaw's proof
will be there
thank you though well well we've got a
slight hiatus and with the misread
mentioning counselor shaw's appendices
i haven't got a hard copy of those um so
if i can have that prior to council shaw
giving her evidence that'd be helpful
thank you
i think we've got we can find it
4.09
from ecce
one of the electronic documents are
actually in a way easier i've forgotten
because you just point to a pdf page
number and then
and then you're there
sorry mr parker said i wasn't uh i was
just if that was directed at me i wasn't
listening it was it was yeah i was just
muttering to myself really
have you got that cancer leaves right
let's now that we've we've got it let's
have a look at what it is it was
referred to this morning
it's the um the single corporate
response from the growth and development
team at ecc can you see that
yeah so it deals with a number of topics
but one of the topics it deals with is
highways
and
that starts on page 11.
okay got that yeah
and i won't read it out but if we just
scan down we can see
that they've
said that they've comprehensively
assessed the supporting material
talk about the transport assessment and
then referred to the the five junctions
that we're now talking about here site
access victory road
daley's road hall road etc
then it refers to
a series of measures that could mitigate
the proposed development
in bullet points
then over the page
can you see this paragraph that starts
the junction modeling
yep okay
so it says the junction modeling has
shown the traffic generated by the
development will impact on the junction
i think they should say junctions
assessed
but with the proposed mitigated i mean
let's say mitigation in place in
partnership with sustainable travel
measures
the impact will be reduced to provide
for nil detriment
or in some cases improvement now let's
think about junction four
in terms of
physical mitigation to what extent is
there any physical changes proposed on
that junction there are no okay
so
to get to nil detriment on sustainable
travel measures at that junction that's
what i want to ask you about
can i have your view on the extent to
which you think sustainable travel
measures
will take the position at junction 4
from the delay that you talked us
through down to a position of nil
detriment to junction 4.
i think it's pretty obvious that it's
not possible
a new detriment i mean it's already been
proved in the graph that we've looked at
that there will be a detriment
and um
no i just can't can't see any
possibility of any improvement there
okay thank you
right
i think we move on then to the final
topic which is rectory road
and safety concerns at the victory road
roundabouts so
you deal with this in your proof
starting at paragraph 3.5
yep
um and can you
just read out 3.5 to 3.6
with regard to the proposal for the
widening of the ashington road rectory
road roundabouts to two lanes we've been
here before
as part of a previous development the
widening to two lanes to access this
roundabout was previously proposed as
part of a package of highway measures to
mitigate the impact of that development
on congestion and the local highway
network this was implicitly implemented
and simply did not work
i say that the previous widening of the
access to the roundabout didn't work as
the two-lane entrance into the
roundabout was subsequently changed back
to one okay and then you've put in a
rebuttal
that's
set out a bit more information on this
i just want you to talk us through the
appendices to this so can we start off
with appendix 2 which is the google
earth
photos
okay uh hang on just one minute i'm
sorry
yep i've got them
so
this is a series of
google of satellite images we've got
2013 2017
and then over the page into 2018 and
2020.
in terms of
we'll come on to why and and the
implications in a minute just in terms
of physically what's there at the
junction can you just talk us through
what we can see on each of these photos
sure if we start at the earliest one
with 2013
you'll see that there's
been an island painted there which has
been
badly
that the paint has badly fallen away
and that's on the rectory road junction
where it comes in from the left of the
photograph onto the ashenton road which
is the
road effectively going north south on
the photograph
go down to 2017 it is still there but
what you can see
is that the painting on the island there
from the rectory road has virtually
disappeared
and that is because
um it is you it was a flat
um a road there just used as um a market
migration in the road there which meant
that people were using it as a two-lane
approach
now
what then happened was if you look at
2018
they repainted that
to try and get people to
adhere
to the original idea there that didn't
work
and so in 2000 well i've got a local
highways report that that the work was
completed in 2018-19
period
on what you see on 2020 where there is
actually a raised
[Music]
island in the middle there preventing
people from being able to drive side by
side there or
as the safety
report
noted uh allowing motorists to enter
into the
roundabout early yeah i mean okay so
that's the changes over time
um
now you said in your you said just then
you said in your proof that there was a
report that resulted in the island being
installed in 2018 2019.
yes that's the that says appendix one
yes
it says site report essex highways
casualty reduction site yep
can you just
tell us what you want the inspector to
to note in this report
yeah there's um a particular
on the second page of that
that report
if you skip down to the middle on other
uh and i'll read the uh the notes that
have been put in there during the site
inspection a number of motorists joining
the roundabout from rectory road
undercut the roundabout the roundabout
island this is likely due to the
position of the roundabout island
combined with the thermoplastic splitter
island that can be overrun
moreover there is good visibility to the
right for motorists approaching the
junction from rectory road and is likely
that motorists are making a decision to
enter the junction early and failing to
stop and check when entering
my concern
there
is that exactly what is being proposed
for that junction
is introducing back
the dangers
that were dealt with by this mitigation
in 2018-19
therefore making the um
the actual
junction
less safe
thank you
um
i think that's the end of what i wanted
to cover is there anything else you want
to add that we haven't already gone
through
i think it's just the the point that
having lived in the area all my life i
have experienced a huge increase in
traffic in the area
and i seriously do not see any way that
this can be mitigated against we're
already looking at
these reports that have been produced
for us that do say
that traffic will be
beyond capacity
and therefore as a council we felt it
was the right thing to do as we were
commission to do
due diligence on this
to
categorise what we saw we saw and what
we as locals experience to categorize
the situation there as severe
and which is the reason being why we
felt it was right
to
put the
application
into um
a no-go
thank you thank you and so does all my
questions
okay thank you very much uh mr parkinson
and council reeves as we said um at the
start of this uh
last session
we'll call it a day here rather than
moving on to any cross-examination but
that will be what we'll begin with
tomorrow
so
let me just run through a few things
that i need to now
bear with me
so um one of the things i was going to
do was ask for the attendance list back
i i have been given that can i just
check is there anyone present who hadn't
signed the attendance list who wishes to
so so there's a few more perhaps perhaps
one from the council could just collect
this and
let let others
thank you very much thank you so if you
haven't signed it if you put your
details on that please
um
[Music]
let me just ask as well this is two the
main part is
um again if i can find my
bit of paper here we go
time estimates i just um
i was i was going to ask you this
when we started this afternoon session
because i got the same thing at the back
of my mind about whether or not we would
complete council reeves and obviously
we've resolved that matter but can i
more or less rely on the time estimates
that you've given is there any changes
to them that no okay so on that basis
i'll have a look um tonight and just see
how i see the rest of the inquiry
panning out and we can discuss that
first thing tomorrow
so i'll do that
um
attend this list again in a minute i i
would encourage um those who are
attending simply to observe to take
advantage of the fact that the inquiry
is being live streamed as i said at the
outset i'm saying this to try and ensure
that we only have the people attending
the venue who are strictly needed to
ensure that the inquiry can progress
um
just so that we can be all as safe as as
possible
um
a re reminder about this schedule of
conditions that you may well have been
sent to the inspectorate
um
i'm i'm happy to take it by close of
play tomorrow which is what i said if by
any chance it exists in a hard copy form
now i'll take it now but i'm not i'm not
trying to spring that on anyone
i think we're printing them out for
tomorrow but tomorrow that's fine let me
let me have it then
um
update on the section 106 i'm not
expecting you to necessarily have told
me that much has happened since this
morning but i'm going to keep on
mentioning that just so that it's
uppermost in your mind that you'll be
trying to
to chase that
and the final bit on my little list here
is a hard copy of councillor shaw's
appendices which i said
i see your
your neighboring colleague has got one
ready to
that's that's great oops thank you very
much it's very helpful
so i'll put that safe
so um
i don't think i've got anything more
that i need to say before we adjourn for
today
what about start time tomorrow i was i
was thinking we'd still go for 10
o'clock tomorrow is that
okay with everyone or is anyone thinking
we need to move to half nine
no
let's let's do let's do 10 o'clock
tomorrow i may take the opportunity to
do a little bit of driving around before
we start so do that
okay anything that any of the parties
need to address me on before i adjourn
no
shakes of heads
so i'm waiting for the attendance list
to come back i can come back after i've
adjourned i'm happy for that but on that
note thank you all for attending
i'll join now and we'll resume tomorrow
at 10 o'clock thank you
you